foreign
hey everybody it's Labor Day yes so
hopefully some of you guys got the day
off work
yeah I never get this it's a three-day
weekend
[Laughter]
I don't really have normal work days
it's just every day every day's work day
but you can also don't have a boss so
that's true you guys are the boss you
got you guys the show schedule is the
only thing that really kind of dictates
well no because uh your graphic design
companies have deadlines yeah that's
right other than that but yeah but yeah
we went out last night that was pretty
fun I didn't really I didn't really
drink all that much so I don't feel too
bad today I'm just kind of sleepy
because I didn't get much sleep yeah
it's pretty good it was a fun night
though yeah she said that I woke her up
from snoring I'm getting kicked out of
my own bed all the time
I gotta sleep in the man cave I might as
well get another bed for the man cave
you don't always snore but like
sometimes you do and it wakes me up so I
got into the habit of [ __ ] sleeping
out there the past month or so though I
kind of like it
what you got well you can go in there
you can snore all you want you can like
you can watch your tablet and like watch
videos and stuff without keeping me
awake
you get a more comfortable mattress
though that mattress is leaking that air
mattress a good thing I tested it here I
wouldn't take that to the field I don't
know I can't find the leak in it
by the way what was Pookie up to last
night she was making noise again right
here she got into not last night but the
other night she got into the um the
cabinet like underneath Tom's bathroom
sink and she threw out a can of spray
paint yeah
Dodge spray paint it's like yeah and
like it woke me up at night though no I
just said that I said it wasn't last
night it was a night or two ago okay and
I came out and like then she comes out
of the bathroom and then she's like what
I didn't she's like I didn't do it I
didn't do anything I'm like what did you
do throwing a spray paint spray [ __ ]
well she knows how to open the cabinet
like she crawls in there and like hides
and then she can open it and like Chuck
stuff out so I've seen her stand up on
her back legs and try to get to my
walkie-talkies and chew on the engine
tennis and I know they think she's
trying to get them she's reaching out
there trying to grab him because I have
like five of them and I was like Pookie
no she's looking over uh I wasn't doing
anything
she has that face like what I was just
trying to grab the walkie-talkie so
because I know what would happen as soon
as she'd pull the walkie-talkie off and
it hit on the ground and then she'd look
around and see he's not watching and she
started chewing on the end I had to
replace one already just another little
cat teeth marks in him she likes things
that are kind of like she knows she
knows she's not supposed to yeah so if
your back is turned she'll totally do it
yeah but then if you look at her if you
look at her she's like yeah
I should try to play it off I was just
rubbing it see yeah that's just right if
you've got any tape over your little
tablets I put tape over the camera on
the cameras on the tablets and [ __ ] when
you're not looking she'll go up there
and try to pull that tape off she's I
wasn't gonna take the tape off
she knows yeah she knows and then you're
not looking and she's looking at you
like that and she's she'll go turn the
head sideways like she's gonna try to
get the tape off this what are you doing
uh
this this show Legend Trippers this
episode
um one of our subscribers is connected
with the people with the case uh I think
it was the guy who runs the paranormal
investigation website is that is that
who he knows do you remember oh no I
don't remember which one remember he
said I remember who said it but he's
requested it several times and it was up
there actually this has been requested
by a couple of people like two or three
people so we were like yeah we had to
get around to this one I think there's
two more that have been requested
um I think one's called the presence and
one called somebody said there was one
called The Counselor but I don't even
remember that one but uh we bought
season eight yeah the other day so we've
been watching some of that online which
yeah we bought those online like we did
get a hard copy and the thing about it
is that we started watching some of them
and I was like I've seen most of these
but it's been like such a long time I
think we watched them like during their
first run on TV yeah it still might as
well be the same as and see here's the
thing
Jenny says we got to watch something
from matinee tomorrow it's got to be
easy might as well just [ __ ] do
another haunting like we did the other
time the the two for last time because
she's tired I don't think she'll make it
through a whole movie
yeah that might be a good idea so
actually yeah maybe we'll do a bonus
haunting like we did the other week that
was popular yeah yeah everybody really
likes these gotta do them anyway and we
got to do them anyway so we might as
well either we'll do like the presents
which some people have requested or
we'll do one from season eight you
should do the mummy one
that was that was like simultaneously
one of the stupidest things I've ever
seen and also one of the most
entertaining things I've ever seen
I think the dude's trolling I think he
was too but like I said if we I don't
know maybe we'll do that one baby we
won't I don't know but like I said
Legend Trippers like people would be
more interested in the classic ones that
they take that's what I'm saying yeah I
mean later on we should do that because
that shit's like [ __ ] that was I'm
sitting there going really dude I don't
think so being attacked by [ __ ] soap
so big Egyptian god so big yeah [ __ ] out
of here who is a good guy he was a good
guy yeah he was a Christian oh [ __ ]
Billy what's his name Billy Billy Bean
what's behind that story I think wasn't
he he was on a lot of the later ones
that's what I meant like when I met like
the later hauntings got like real
churchy like they had a bunch of like
Billy Bean ones because man that [ __ ]
had like his own episode about like oh
my house was haunted by a demon when I
was a kid or some [ __ ] like that and
then like he grew up and became like a
preacher or whatever the hell he was and
so he went and investigated like other
people's demon problems yeah and then so
he had like multiple episodes where he
would turn up and get I talked to Billy
Bean online years back and uh tried to
talk with him and I wasn't impressed at
all I
I wouldn't believe the thing that came
out of Billy Bean's mouth
yeah he doesn't he didn't pass much it
doesn't seem super credible no I mean
you know he's I don't know the dude so
I'm not trying to cast aspersions but
religious charlatan Jeffy Hart says
Pookie's trying to start her own podcast
when you guys aren't looking uh honestly
it wouldn't shock me
um she's probably doing all kind of like
nefarious [ __ ] like that that we don't
know about
um Danny Rowling said just like The
Haunting in Florida dude that you know
get him on too just saying yeah man he's
on my Facebook you know I've talked to
him all the time but I haven't seen him
I haven't talked to him in a few years
he's a little ex-army Ranger we mostly
talk about the Army though we're [ __ ]
then he ended up becoming a justice of
the peace and he'd give you a ranger
[ __ ] wedding
uh while he's wearing his Kilt he's
dressed up in a range with killed in
this Scottish outfit I don't know if
he's still doing that but uh he's in and
out the man in a kilt yeah he's uh he's
in and out of the construction business
depending on what the hell's going on
but
um no talking to him about what happened
up there in in Deltona
um no he passed the smell test with me
just his attitude I talked to him on the
phone I mean he's on the phone before I
met him
oh man remember I talked to you yeah
yeah yeah yeah I ran into him just by
chance he's working at the hardware
store he was working at the hardware
store like right up the street from our
old house which is crazy yep then one
time I was in traffic [ __ ] ride up on
pulling up on a bill and looked over to
the car my right and he was sitting
there driving I [ __ ] went up this
what's up man hey
he's just a big old Burley next Ranger
guy who got divorced from that woman
who's in that episode
um the marriage broke apart but he still
had good terms with his kids and
everything he just hangs around locally
but uh no [ __ ] his story kind of
reminded me a lot of the things that he
said so I don't give out a lot of
information what I'm questioning these
guys
I wanna I just asked questions that I
kind of Judge their responses of what
certain things felt like and what they
did
and his story passed the smell test with
me because it
it's a lot like what happened to me and
that not so much uh Mammoth Mountain but
that uh that bad house I was in that his
house was a bad house
but there was apparitions so his so his
was a couple notches above mine I
believed him I believed him and I also
believed it scared him kind of crazy
which it can do that to you he's not
crazy I'm just saying that it can the
fear can make you irrational and it made
him violent you talked about it in the
episode
well we kind of got into and actually
one of the other I think it was the
season eight episode that we were
watching and we kind of laughed because
one of the guys on there said pretty
much the same thing that we said sort of
like ingest on some of the other shows
about it's like dudes can't like handle
a lot of the dudes that are on a
haunting like can't really handle the
haunting because they can't punch it you
can't punch it and the guy pretty much
said almost exactly that like word for
word and I laughed because I was like
see he's saying it he admitted it it's
like we can't punch it so we're out of
ideas
basically yeah and um he was an ex
ranger battalion we call them bad boys
he wasn't tabbed but he was from the
range of battalions he was in there
several years
big guy six six feet easy a heavy weight
and he couldn't shoot it he couldn't
[ __ ] punch it and he couldn't yell it
out of existence in fact it just fueled
it which that checks out that checks out
with what I saw with Poltergeist
and uh that's what would happen if you
confronted that thing it would just get
more violent that but we never really
confronted it that way we knew better
but a dude like him no he'd try to fight
it which had become violent
um I can imagine like that bad house if
that bad house that I was in had the
ability to do what a poltergeist could
do and could make a apparitions
apparitions of the Dead that would be a
bad combination you wouldn't want to
make that situation worse by throwing
violence into it
a lot of that stuff just doesn't would
not react the way you would think you
can't directly confront it that like
that way you'll make it worse
what are you going to do to that thing
it's non-physical
it's in a slightly different dimension
and a lot of it might be playing
directly on your mind like an apparition
let's say you see an apparition was that
Apparition really there or did it put
that that image in your mind was it
slightly a hallucination that it forced
into you I don't know I don't know I've
never heard of anybody been able to
photograph an apparition
every photograph of an apparition I've
seen it's been faked
I tend to think what it is it directly
puts that image into your mind
because I tell you what in that one bad
house they could directly put fear into
your mind
it was just it was just generalized you
didn't know what you were afraid of
though felt like something was on the
other side of the door or somebody's
watching you be terrified to open up
that door like there was something there
but there was nothing there
it wasn't just you man girls would come
over and they'd have to walk them to the
bathroom and wait outside the bathroom
we're in the house I'm waiting outside
the bathroom and then pee scared of that
house
not just me well that seems to be a
pretty common thing that like people
report in haunting situations is that
the first thing before they even see
anything or [ __ ] starts moving around or
anything they're always like I felt like
I was being watched or I felt like there
was somebody behind me and then I turned
around and there's nobody there [ __ ]
like that wasn't as bad as Poltergeist
though now the mountain of feelings were
more intense
so I was already kind of a veteran when
I saw the bad house later on
but other people couldn't hang because
it was just so vague
you felt a threat but you couldn't put
your finger on what it was and it didn't
it never moved anything never saw any
apparitions it was all just emotional
it was weird
so I couldn't prove anything because it
was all internal
now if it's stronger do you see
apparitions yeah maybe maybe it might
have just be strong enough to make you
think you saw something but maybe you
all see the same things because it was
some kind of outside force that
projected that mental image into your
mind and you you all did see it but it
wasn't there you couldn't photograph it
you know psychic like you know psychic
abilities of a [ __ ] some kind of a
extra dimensional
force or a being dark place was strong
with the dark side
Tammy says I wouldn't complain about an
extra haunting show maybe we should do
one like I said because they're fast and
easy they're yeah I mean they're not
yeah they're they're more fun to do the
the episodes are shorter like we've seen
them a bunch of times so it's like yeah
I usually have to watch them once or
twice so I can like take notes and stuff
but we've seen the episodes moving
multiple times yeah it's not really that
big a deal yeah so maybe we'll do
another one tomorrow maybe we'll do
we'll maybe we'll do the presents
because I know somebody we get super
Chats on them that's true then we get
super everybody seems to appreciate him
to give super chats and get hits on them
areasa says uh the hungry ghosts we
actually did an episode a long time ago
like not one of these it wasn't a live
stream but we did actually an episode I
don't remember how good it was but we
did a an episode a long time ago on that
we might like revisit it at some point
because Tom really likes that episode
yeah I actually we talked me and Jenny
talked about this earlier
is that maybe we should do redos on a
lot of the old stuff because it's way
back in the catalog and some of that
stuff the Recording Technology we're
using might not have been the best
microphones that we had and uh
some of those some of those episodes
might be good as a redo and Hungry Ghost
is one of them that's one of my favorite
episodes that was a good episode a
strong case I like that one the strong
case and that checks out with some of
the stuff that I personally have kind of
seen with the way certain things go the
whole Taoist angle is also good real
good
oh I liked it because it was unusual
like it stood out you know what I mean
uh uh some kind of a
invisible force that had
I guess
sexual desires towards these young women
I've heard of that set on several
different cases
some kind of a disembodied
male being
the dead maybe
or you know I don't want to see demon I
don't really like to use those kind of
words you know because that's kind of
charged each culture has their own way
of describing things you know Christians
are going to say demons Muslims are
going to say [ __ ] you know gin you
know which
I'm going to say it was just more like
just uh some kind of an evil force
something bad
an extra dimensional being it might be a
life form it may be the memory of a life
form you don't know
Danny Rowling said Bill Bean talks about
Bigfoot as well of course he does yeah I
didn't he didn't pass the smell test but
I talked to him before he was well known
just based on another case that he saw
and um I just wanted to check it check
check him out
and if he passed the test maybe
collaborate on a book but he didn't pass
the test
that was before I found Steve Mara Steve
I talked to Steve Marin he passed the
test and we did we've done books with
him yeah Steve's awesome man I need to
read getting I haven't talked to Steve
in [ __ ] a couple there actually yeah
yeah we wrote a couple books with him
yeah Steve Steve is a cool dude and very
fair okay he
approaches everything as maybe it's
possible if it happened maybe it's this
this and this maybe it didn't happen
maybe it's this and this and this so
he's well he's like an old school
parapsychologist like which I wish they
would kind of bring back but yeah he's
more into uh not telling you what it was
giving you all the options of possibly
what it could be and then he'll kind of
do some Source stuff about well these
guys back in the 60s would say this that
it was rspk you know or so he's real
good at that kind of stuff there are a
couple of projects He got involved with
that I think was a little bit of
commercialism but you know that's
happens with everybody you know if a gig
goes but comes by you go you know if I
do this I might get some more notoriety
in my better material will get promoted
so it's understandable some of the stuff
that happens
the um
he is I guess you could say for him
parapsychology and the stuff around it
is a business
so in a business you have to do certain
things from a business standpoint but
out of
out of out of the dudes that are doing
this for a business he's one of the best
ones because his good material is very
balanced
you know I just yeah he really doesn't
come across to me as somebody that would
just like believe anything he's very
like scientifically minded yeah he's
like if this happened then here are the
ex multiple explanations of what it
could be yeah and that's how you
approach it he doesn't jump right to
Dean obviously demon it was demons or
whatever
Steve would go well okay if it's a demon
what is a demon let's talk about demons
and they need to give all the layouts of
what a demon could be you know
because there's a lot of different
explanations of what a demon is
some of them come from old religious
manuscripts and religious books
but that's just one opinion could a
psychic force in another dimension that
of a bad person would you interpret that
as a demon when you saw it yeah you
would
you know would it be a demon how do you
define demon the Bible the you know the
the Jewish and the Christian Bibles say
that demons are the sons of God that
have been cast out and fallen from
Heaven put in Chains because they cross
bred with human females like back in
Genesis or they rebelled and did some
things and that these are angels
you know Angels punished Angels what's
an angel an angel's a [ __ ] demigod
it's one of God's children's the sons of
God so you're talking about Zeus and the
uh the his children that he had with
Hera you know
it's just a I guess you could say a
Jewish version of the
of the what do you call it the Greek
pantheon
so no wouldn't be a demon and wouldn't
be a demon in that way it'd be a demon
in the in the
in the idea of an evil spirit you know I
can buy that
but as described in the Bible what a
demon was no because an angel's had all
this power
and what would they be doing [ __ ]
around with kids
you know would they be doing haunt the
house
if someone's not in a house it's just an
evil spirit that's something that always
kind of bothered me it's like why would
a why would a super powerful demon yeah
like why would they even bother
like let's possess this one one kid kid
for shits and giggles and make this off
this priest yeah it's like would never
happen why would they do that it'd be
more likely it was just some kind of an
evil I remember if I was a demon I'm
sure I could think of better ways to
occupy my time that's all I'm saying if
stuff like that is happening and if it
is an outside force it's more likely to
be just an evil spirit of some sort
and then you have to figure out what
kind of evil spirits maybe it's just
where did they Coast it was like it's a
ghost like a person that was a real
douche it's a real douche yeah or maybe
it's just a part of the soul of an evil
person maybe a person dies and he casts
out the evil energies from himself and
then that evil energy lives on by itself
as a a fraction of a soul an evil piece
of a soul you know it's not even a full
person you know that's a possibility
there's no way of knowing
you're talking about all theoretical
[ __ ]
but it's interesting ideas
sure I've seen poltergeists that have
been in bad houses and you can you'll
never be able to nail it down your
senses can't pick up will not be able to
gather enough information you can't see
what's happening in other dimensions you
know for example and they kind of defy
investigation whatever it is it does not
want you to know what it is
just something that's kind of weird
weird or weird or bad or both
all right so can we get to the let's
talk you can do it but it looks like you
got a good crowd or I'll wait let's talk
about the episode so like I said this
has been requested multiple times I
think this uh this episode Legend
Trippers was requested more than any
other one okay so this was season four
episode 13 so I believe this was
actually the last episode of season four
it was like somebody mentioned earlier
that it was like the uh the finale
episode that came out around Halloween
which is why it's structured a lot
differently yeah it's different than any
of the other ones it's almost kind of
like I don't want to say it's like a
compilation it is it's a little bit of a
yeah well the weird thing about it is
that they when they do kind of like a
little uh models I don't know what to
say monologue but like little monologue
thing like at the beginning and they're
talking about oh like or like different
urban legends and folklore and stuff and
they actually show clips from a bunch of
different episodes like from That season
so I thought that was kind of
entertaining so yeah it's this one is
not as straightforward it's not like a
haunted house
it covers it's mostly urban legends that
are surrounding this one Cemetery
Dartford Cemetery which is in Green Lake
Wisconsin but it does mention a couple
of other ones as well and it kind of
covers like a couple of different people
and I'm not entirely sure why they I
don't know it's just like I said the
structure of it is very odd like they
did like this weird like nested kind of
thing and I'm not entirely sure that
they had to do it like that but you know
they just chose to write it like that
and that's fine I'm not eating so uh so
yeah
so basically as I mentioned this is
mostly centered around Green Lake
Wisconsin
now what you have is
okay so you have like at first you have
sort of a framing device
now there's a group of friends it's a
girl and two guys
and they're going to this Cemetery which
like I said Dartford Cemetery now the
cemetery that they show in the episode
it's it's cool it's very atmospheric and
stuff that's not the actual Cemetery
although they do show the actual actual
one like later on in the show and it
looks similar so I'm assuming they just
found a closer buy one I don't really
know that they could shoot in that was
not gonna like interrupt people or
whatever
so uh so yeah so you have these three
friends now these three friends one of
the guys and one of the girls I don't
think and I watched this episode like
two times and I've like Fast forwarded
and like rewound and stuff through there
I don't think they named one of them
like the one guy who I think his name is
Corbin Van Buren which of course I
remember that because what a weird name
but um it's not weird it's kind of
awesome actually but uh yeah so he was
actually on the show but he was kind of
like one of the friends that's like in
the framing device
so at the beginning they're talking
about uh the three of them they're like
we we go to this Dartford Cemetery which
is supposed to be haunted
and then we go there and there's like
the whole urban legend about this place
is that there's a mausoleum in the
middle of the cemetery
that if you sit on top of it it's not
like a huge building thing it's kind of
like I don't know it's probably like a
little taller than a person it looked
like seven or eight feet tall I guess
and so you can like pretty easily like
climb up there and sit on the roof of it
so the legend goes that if you sit on
the roof of this mausoleum in Dartford
Cemetery then a ghost will push you off
so that's so they're kind of going there
to like check that out and before they
do that though there's also this other
gravestone which I don't think the
gravestone in particular is haunted but
it is actually kind of like
um supposedly the burial place of one of
the ghosts that does haunt the place
there's a really creepy like Indian
chief
um grave there now the grave that they
showed in the episode was pretty creepy
looking and I saw the real one and that
is also very creepy looking but in a
different way I think that the one on a
haunting they made it look more
classically creepy like in a horror
movie whereas the real one
the real one I kind of got the feeling
that whoever made it like whoever carved
it or however or painted it or whatever
they didn't actually intend for it to be
creepy but it just kind of turned out
that way so it's kind of creepy and a
different like in an unintentional
unintentionally creepy whereas the one
in the episode is more like let's make
it look creepy like a horror movie
okay so these three friends
go to uh go to the cemetery and they
just basically they sit up on the
mausoleum and then they're like now I'm
gonna tell you the story about these
other three kids who go to our school
that did this last year or whatever
because I think they went in Fall of
2006 and I think the thing with the
previous kids happened like on Halloween
of 2005 if I'm not mistaken so they're
like okay so last Halloween like this
scary [ __ ] happened and these kids they
went to our school so then they go back
and start talking about these other
three kids
so all right so the first group that
went there on Halloween of 2005. now
these three actually all three of them
were on the show like were interviewed
for the show right so the main guy is
named Nick Weber
and he at the time that this happened in
2005 he was 16 years old and he said he
lived with his mom in Montello Wisconsin
which was about 25 miles away from Green
Lake where the cemetery is
now at this point like Nick is given a
little bit of background he says
you know my mom and dad had just
divorced not too long before so my mom
had to like work extra so I never really
saw much of her
you know what I mean because she always
came home like really late at night now
the town that he lived in Montello
Wisconsin only had 1400 people living in
it at the time so you can imagine that
the teenagers that lived there were like
super [ __ ] bored like all the goddamn
time and we're always looking for
something to do to entertain themselves
so Halloween's coming up and Nick starts
looking online to find something creepy
to do on Halloween and he comes across
this website that has a database of all
this haunted stuff in Wisconsin now uh
the guy that put together the website he
was also interviewed on the show and his
name is Chad Lewis and the website
interestingly is still live and it still
looks pretty much exactly the same as it
did on the show like in 2005. it looks
like they haven't updated it I don't
know if he's just like paying to keep it
open and he's just like not doing
anything like to design it but it looked
because I kind of laughed because I went
and found it yeah and I was like oh my
God it looks exactly the same as it did
on the show like they haven't updated it
which I thought was kind of hilarious
but it's like I mean it's basically just
kind of like a list it's just kind of
like a list of like you know different
haunted places in Wisconsin so it's not
like it has to be like all beautiful and
everything it's just like kind of funny
so uh so they interviewed Chad Lewis the
guy that runs the website
and he says he was always interested in
folklore and stuff like that so that's
how he got the idea to do the site and
he's like after it went live he said he
was started to get all of these emails
from you know local teenagers it's not
he doesn't do just Wisconsin but it's
mostly that area
and um he's like so I started getting
all these messages from all these
teenagers that were doing what they
called Legend trips uh you know title
drop hence the name of the episode
um and what they would do is you know
they would just go around to all these
locations and like see what they could
see like see if there was like some
haunting [ __ ] going on because that's
kind of what you do like I said you
don't have anything better to do
so then they kind of go a little bit
into some other
now okay now I want to get into this a
little bit but
let me talk about this first so they
actually talk about before they even get
into Dartford Cemetery which is kind of
like the main bulk of the episode
they talk about at least one other
uh Legend from around this area now one
of these Legends concerns a place called
witch Road and I'm going to talk about
more about like the real place because I
did actually like look this place up
now supposedly a witch once lived there
uh hence the name wish Road and the
house is still there in the woods it's
not like it's all like [ __ ] up and
ruined and everything like that like you
can't live in or nothing now on the show
they said uh there's a bunch of stories
about it but they talked about this one
story where there was a couple who drove
out there one day with their
four-year-old son and I guess the dad
was all Jack he's like oh I want to go
take a picture of the witch house or
whatever so they drive out there the
wife is totally not into it
and while the mom and the son are like
waiting by the car because they're like
yeah we're just gonna wait right here
you just go off in the woods and take
pictures of witch house you have fun
with that and so then the sun kind of
walks around the car and like starts
talking to an invisible person
and so his mom comes around and say like
Hey kid Michael whatever the hell the
kid's name was
um you know who are you talking to and
the little boy says I'm talking to the
nice little girl who lives in the woods
you know and uh so the mom's like yep
I'm out and uh so there she like calls
the husband back like come on we're
getting the [ __ ] out of here right now
because shit's on it now uh so
apparently like other people have also
reported seeing this little girl in the
woods uh but nobody seems quite sure who
she is now as I said I looked up Chad
Lewis's website which again looks just
the same as it did in 2005. and what he
has to say about which road because it's
a real place it's in Rosendale in Fond
du Lac County in Wisconsin uh the name
of the road is not which road obviously
it's actually Callan Road c-a-l-l-a-n
that's the name of the road that it's uh
on
and what are you doing I accidentally uh
turned your turn the uh speaker on on
that yeah knock that [ __ ] off okay
it's a new it's a new uh tablet he
doesn't know how it works the control is
a little bit different on it trying to
get to the uh damn comment section so he
says on his website he says the the
supposed history of this place was that
50 or 60 years ago there was a witch
living in this house on which road
obviously and they just named the street
after her because that was nice
um and the road is haunted ever since uh
by the ghost of a little girl how What
relation is the little girl of the witch
no one seems to know but that's what
everybody's reported
um so people have reported from around
this area and like I said they didn't
mention this on the show but I found
this on the website
um several people have reported on this
particular stretch of road uh certain
parts of the road are like uh darker
than they should be and colder than they
should be
um you can also hear kind of like
trickling water like near the road even
though there's supposedly like not any
water around there like running water
around there uh The Witch's House is
still there as I mentioned people have
seen flashing lights at the end of the
road and white lights have been observed
uh on the trees I'm not like on the
trees or in the trees it said on the
trees I'm like what does that mean like
does that mean the trees are glowing or
a white light coming through the trees
I guess I would have thought yeah I
would have thought that if you'd said
through the trees you would have said
that right yeah no on the tree implies
that they're like glowing yeah or it's
kind of like somebody shining a
flashlight on the top of the tree you
know what I mean so you can see it
something like that maybe that's what I
mean I know it's like but I know I think
too much about this well like I said I
guess I'm a writer so I'm very like well
I'm very into like I'm like well you
used that word are you are you using
that exactly the way you meant to use
that or were you just not it's just
about to say [ __ ] well I know that
obviously I do that too but I'm just
saying that sometimes and particularly
if you put something in writing where
presumably you can read it back and be
like oh that's not exactly the word I
wanted to use there
um so I don't know that was just
something I'm like on the trees where is
that Samantha says where is this it's in
uh Wisconsin this actually which road is
in Rosendale in Fond du Lac County uh
verica Z good evening everybody I'm
pretty new to your channel you guys are
so cute oh thank you thank you very much
thank you well welcome we have a good
time doing this
but this is this is very I mean we used
to do haunting episodes all the time but
like when we just recently started doing
these again everybody seems to be really
into this like I said we might do
another one tomorrow we probably will do
another one tomorrow Samantha saying
where is this this is I said it's in
Wisconsin Wisconsin yeah it's in
Wisconsin
um yeah so uh so light on the tree
whatever that means uh there's also a
tree on the side of the road that
resembles the witch which you know that
seems kind of like okay that should just
be natural and uh as I said a lot of
people it seem like a ghost of a little
girl uh hiding in the woods peeking out
from behind the trees and Etc and Chad
said that they went and did an
investigation and they found the house
and uh they're like well they don't
really know that much about it they did
find like a little Brook that was kind
of like going along the road he said
well that might explain why people are
hearing running water when they think
there's no running water
um but that's pretty much it they didn't
see anything all that mysterious now
here's the weird thing
please tell me if you remember this or
not and maybe I got it confused with
another episode because I know that we
watched a couple of other ones like
subsequently
I thought that when they were talking
about like they talked about which road
right and they were talking about like
other urban legends that happened like
around this area of Wisconsin I could
have sworn that they mentioned
a urban legend an urban legend about
like a girl that had died in a car
accident like along a particular stretch
of road and then and her dad was out
there yeah the ghost of her dad you know
what's weird I watched the episode again
yeah and I couldn't find that bit
oh it's there we saw it together I know
but I watched it again like in here yeah
and I kept like I'm like where the [ __ ]
is it I'm like I know I saw that
skipping it you must have skipped it no
I swear to God
I swear to God so I don't know if the
version that I watched online like
they'd cut that part out for some reason
okay you watched an online version yeah
it was cut out that's like maybe it was
cut out for time or something yeah
because I'm sitting there going I must
be [ __ ] crazy I'm like I could have
sworn that they brought up another urban
legend yeah and then for research
purposes we we have all these on DVD
yeah and then I watched it again like
online the next day in my office because
I was too lazy to walk down the hall and
get the DVD but um yeah so I just
watched it again online and then that
wasn't in there and I was like God I
could have sworn and I remembered it so
I went back and watched and I rewound
and like Fast Forward I'm like where the
[ __ ] is it I'm like I know it's here it
must have been cut out because I went
all through the [ __ ] and I didn't see it
again I watched it through like two
times and it wasn't there
it's not crazy yeah so yeah because I
was kind of and then the weird thing too
is then I went to Chad Lewis's website
because I thought that they showed him
like clicking on oh here's this other
weird they only they really only spent
like a minute or two on it where they
said oh it's a stretcher road I don't
even remember what stretch of road it
was if they even mentioned it and they
said yeah this girl got killed in a car
accident it's like not even the girls
ghost that haunts it like it's her dad
so they're like it's really weird like
he's like turned around he's all bloody
and stuff like that and he's like where
have you seen my daughter or some [ __ ]
like that because I remember you reacted
you were like holy [ __ ] because it was
like kind of creepy so I was like I
don't know I thought that was really
weird that they didn't and then when I
watched it back I was like I could have
sworn that was in there and then I
thought well maybe it was in another
episode and I'm getting confused but
that's why I thought I would bring it up
to you but you remembered it okay so
maybe they just cut it out of that
version for time or something or it came
out that that's a book that's [ __ ]
they took that time probably time
that's what I'm thinking maybe
Zach says Mandela effect she switched
realities I know that did occur to me
like for a second I'm like oh my god
well I thought I well because we had
watched a couple other episodes like
after that like the next day so I said
maybe it was a scene from one of those
and I'm like mixing I know the feeling
because scream Blacula scream is missing
a bunch of [ __ ] a bunch of scenes
that I remember have uh seeing in the
earlier versions of it I mean it does
happen sometimes because sometimes they
show like the movie in the theater for
example and then like later on people
don't react all that well to the theater
or later on the director's like I don't
really like that scene let's take it out
so sometimes like when they release it
later like for home for you know home
use sometimes they'll Shuffle scenes
around her and sometimes too they have
like a different cut uh they do this a
lot when they show it on TV like if it's
gonna be um have commercials and stuff
sometimes they have to either shorten it
or lengthen it sometimes if they
lengthen it they'll put like a bunch of
scenes in there that weren't in the the
attribute cut so that happens a lot it's
not so you're not crazy I remember
screaming back black in the scream had a
bunch of uh scenes uh about slavery
in there those scenes actually and rice
used later on in the vampire Chronicles
and so that's where Anne Rice got that
[ __ ]
I uh I bought the [ __ ] deep uh
Blu-ray and those scenes weren't in
there I watched the online version of
the a streamed online one time
I streamed it online twice the first
time I streamed it
in the uh in around 2008 that's when I
saw the scenes I streamed it a few years
later like in 2014 and they weren't
there but I remember those scenes
because they were right out of Anne Rice
well yeah and like I said sometimes
different countries have different cuts
too so sometimes you see like a
different cut like I said sometimes you
see the director's cut or something
there's a bunch of different cuts of the
movies like for various reasons I have a
[ __ ] I will plug Blacula and Screen
black the scream over those were [ __ ]
high quality vampire movies and and rice
[ __ ] her vampire Chronicles were
based on the original cuts of those
they're [ __ ] good I talked about both
of those movies on my over on my scare
Salon Channel which you should go
subscribe to if you have that which if
you're really into horror I'm doing a
whole series which is going to take
forever but I'm doing my five favorite
horror movies from every year since I
was born
so I did 1972 I did 1973. I did 1974. so
yeah Blacula and scream black yellow
screen were in yeah what they cut out is
they cut out the fact that [ __ ]
Blacula made slaves out of people okay
and he he hated that because he was
anti-slavery when he was a human now it
all plays into that Anne Rice thing
because he had a master vampire making
slave vampires
and they cut that out of screened like
the screen unfortunate man because that
was a great [ __ ] twist I mean that's
the essence of what all the stories of
the vampire Chronicles uh from Anne Rice
we're about turning people into vampires
to steal their [ __ ]
and to get them to be your companion
weird [ __ ] but none of those Anne Rice
stories would have would have meant
would have meant that none of those Anne
Rice stories would have ever happened
without the inspiration from [ __ ]
Blacula the screen black of the screen
yeah I feel like those movies are a lot
more uh or deep influential than yeah
than people give them credit for yeah
they're real good because I know like
the title sounds super cheap it sounds
cheesy yeah but they're not really all
that no they're actually really good
they were good yeah
um verica says love the Paranormal I've
been doing research for 15 years so it's
exactly at my alley I found you with the
Sid Vicious video it was great oh yeah I
remember that that was a fun show to do
yeah like we're both rolling into a
little Sid yeah Gotham Punk and
everything like that poor Sid I'm gonna
say poor sit yeah well although he did
kill a cat so I'm not gonna like uh
forgive that sorry
they were they were likely to lie about
that kind of [ __ ] too though
Zach says hey [ __ ] what I miss I was
just having a steak dinner with my man I
know that's not a euphemism
hahaha
I know thoughts are dirty yeah I'm
having a steak dinner yeah
Danny rolling said I like that this
episode had multiple different stories
in it I kind of did too I like that they
sort of did something a little bit
different with it I guess because it was
like I said the finale in the Halloween
episode it's like a greatest hits album
it is kind of from but from uh one
investigator yeah yeah
all right so now let's move on to
Dartford Cemetery which like I said is
kind of like the main legend about this
and like where they spend most of the
time in the episode
uh so yeah and the Dare about the
mausoleum so Nick Weber who like I said
he's he's interviewed on the show he
says well I'm not really sure if I
believed in ghosts or not I was like
open to the possibility
so he decides he's gonna tell his best
friend about this dare like if you sit
on the top of the basily and then a
ghost will push you off
um and he's like hey you want to do this
for Halloween because we don't really
have anything better to do so his
friend's name is Christian Adams uh
Christian Adams was also interviewed on
the show uh and he basically said to
himself he was a troublemaker like we
like these two guys I guess they did
like pranks and [ __ ] like that all the
time
um Nick also says that people have seen
the ghost of the Indian chief like the
one with like the creepy weird grave
like walking around the cemetery like in
all his uh you know finery or whatever
now they also have a third friend whose
name is John Lloyd who was also on the
show now he really really does not like
being scared and doesn't want to do this
whole [ __ ] but is trying to like play it
off like I don't have time for this I
got baseball practice or whatever the
[ __ ] but
um you can tell that he's just like
scared shitless and doesn't want to do
it but the other two guys like
eventually talk him into it now they
both said we specifically did not tell
him about the specifics of the Dare I.E
that if you sit on the top of the
mausoleum in this Cemetery then a ghost
will push you off and this is kind of
important for like some [ __ ] to happen
later on they said that they didn't tell
him that they just said we're gonna go
spend Halloween at a haunted cemetery
and he's like that's in lame but he was
obviously like scared chillas
um so at this point they're kind of
asking them like how they feel about the
Paranormal [ __ ] like that Christian
Adams says he's a Polish immigrant uh
that his parents were very strict Roman
Catholic parents he wasn't really into
like ghosts and all that kind of stuff
uh John Lloyd even though he's scared of
everything uh says he was raised to not
believe in the Paranormal so they're all
kind of coming at it from oh we're
Skeptics kind of thing uh we also
laughed at this particular part in the
episode because all three of the boys
are over at I presume Nick's house
because his mom was working
and it's Halloween night and they're all
sitting around watching Nosferatu now I
don't think they were I'm sure they
weren't watching Nosferatu in real life
maybe they just showed on the episode
because it's in the public domain but um
just like they always have people
watching Night of the Living Dead
because that's also in the public domain
but they're sitting around watching
Nosferatu and John Lloyd is getting like
he's getting ready to pee his pants just
from like watching Nosferatu I'm like
seriously seriously come on
it's a great movie I'm not saying that
but it's like if you're getting scared
watching the original Nosferatu yeah
it's not it's not very scary I mean it's
not really that's scary by today's
standards there are some dudes I
remember them though you know
from my youth that would creep
themselves out you showed them something
in your own imagination this guy seemed
like that that they would no matter what
you did they would [ __ ] no matter
what you showed them they made it five
times worse by creeping themselves out
yeah and they said that he was like that
so yeah I don't think it was Nosferatu
they probably showed him something else
that's what I'm saying but yeah like I
would you know I'd I'd give him some
slack if they were watching something
like really really really scary but I
was just kind of like look and I like I
said I love the original nospara too
it's a great movie but it's not
particularly scary especially by like
today's standards so it's like man you
got some problems if you're a grown ass
man or like a teenage boy and are
watching not speratu and her getting
scared by that the only thing creepy
about nosferatz was the way he looked
well yeah which still looks fantastic
yeah to this day I think yeah oh and by
the way if you would like you guys if
you've never seen shadow of the vampire
from 2001 I think that movie came out
which is like about the making of that
where it's actually like alternative
history where they posit that Max Shrek
the guy that played nosferati was an
actual vampire
um and it's great Willem Dafoe is in it
he plays uh the vampire you probably
like it it's actually really
entertaining
um it's kind of like it's a it's sort of
like a black comedy but a horror movie
but a drama I don't know it's kind of
hard to it's a it's a weird kind of
movie to categorize but it's excellent I
really really like it John Malkovich is
in his hair the creepiest re the
creepiest real vampire of all times that
[ __ ] right there class class
kids Klaus can't see his [ __ ] child
raping ass
allegedly allegedly I don't know yeah
alleged with his dog gotta put that we
don't want to get signed allegedly
[ __ ] that [ __ ] was crazy he
was a crazy man
see crawl space
you [ __ ] creepy in that [ __ ] he was
crazy yeah nobody wanted to work with
him really but they hired him but he was
hard to work with you it was [ __ ]
weird real weird
but that was back in the day where you
could be artiste I guess
well they let people get away with other
people get away back then which like I
don't think that's a good thing no but
um went to his head yeah yeah
that's right Tammy says Eddie his art is
in it too that's right he's in Shadow of
the vampire he plays the guy that played
uh Harker I think in the in the movie
and slash red said one of these days you
should review either the original Clash
of the Titans we haven't done Clash of
the Titans
how could we not have done Clash of the
Titans well we did the Sinbad movies I
well we did some of the Sinbad movies I
know that but it's like I find it very
hard to believe that we have a job I'm
gonna have to look back maybe we did we
did all the Sinbad movies I thought we
eventually got them all maybe we did
but I got that's crazy if we haven't
done clashes because I [ __ ] love
Clash of the Titans see we've done so
many we've done so many shows we can't
remember them all
and well and that's the thing too and
it's like and I probably have a harder
time like remembering too because not
only do we do because I do a bunch of
other movie reviews
by myself and I do like videos of them
and I also write about them so it's like
sometimes I get confused it's like wait
did we do a show about that or did I did
I just do a video about it or did I just
strangely one of the biggest shows that
we did on a movie was was
um
um Logan's Logan's Run for some reason
our Logan's Run has [ __ ] tens of
thousands of [ __ ] hits
I think we did a good show on Logan's
Run and well it was shitty [ __ ]
recording equipment well and I think
that when we put that up there there
wasn't a lot of other right reviews of
it like when we first put that up now
there are but and we had some good takes
on what it was they were talking about
and you know we were we were
we were we're old enough to remember
when that movie came out and what that
meant at the time that it came out and
how Star Wars kicked its ass and it
vanished
but before Star Wars came out Logan's
Run was the best science fiction movie
you could watch
if you were a kid you know we love
Logan's Run people [ __ ] run around
like they were the Sandman and that Star
Wars Star Wars A New Hope came out and
that but that's what I forgot there went
[ __ ]
there went [ __ ] Logans around and the
TV series is good I got it got it on DVD
it's good the TV series was real good
Heather menses
yeah and and they have a [ __ ] dude in
there who was uh he played uh
uh he was in uh the thing and he played
basically data they had a an Android
named Ram in there who kind of steals
the show he's one of the best characters
on the show a lot of same writers from
the old Star Trek it was good it was a
real good show
shitty [ __ ] theme song
it literally goes pew
it does yeah the the the the the yeah
we're not even being facetious not even
being facetious
pew pew pew yeah yeah yeah it's crazy
it's good it's good but if you guys can
watch it I don't know uh see the uh the
Logan's Run
series it's good
uh Zach says have you ever seen the 30s
German movie Vampire I haven't but I'm
going to I want to do that like
sometimes I might not get to it this
month but maybe next month because I
think it's on um HBO Max and that's so
that's one that I put on my list because
that's on there HBO max if you don't
have it like I got it for free with my
phone plan
but um they have a really really good uh
classic movie selection like if you go
to their like AMC like curated stuff
there I got all kinds of good [ __ ] on
there and they have like a lot of like
old classic horror and stuff as well all
right so uh so yeah so we were laughing
about Nosferatu and then yeah like
distracted by that like getting creeped
like I said I'm sure they weren't really
watching Nosferatu because teenage boys
in 2005 wouldn't be watching them no
they were watching something but they
were but not as part two like I said
it's in the public domain so they're
like we can put that on TV and it's
creepy so uh so they go to the cemetery
and uh you know because John's like can
we just go to the cemetery it's like
it's got to be less scary than watching
dos brought to you I guess
um because he didn't want to go at first
but so they get there and they didn't
really plan ahead I'm assuming uh so
they didn't take flashlights although
Nick has like a little one I guess like
in his car on a keychain or some [ __ ]
like that uh John says on the show that
he thought the cemetery was the
creepiest place he'd ever seen and I
think I mentioned earlier but the the
graveyard they use on the show isn't the
real Dartford Cemetery although they do
actually show the real one like later on
I don't think like the one on the show
looks a little bit more like decrepit
you know like the fence and everything
um the the real one like actually has
like a nice like sign that has all the
letters there it doesn't look very old
it doesn't look like a horse I mean it
is but it looks like it's like better
maintenance than the one in the show
they I guess they wanted the one in the
show to look more like a horror movie
kind of thing where it was all like
decrepit and [ __ ] so the first thing
that happens in the cemetery
is Nick feels as though maybe something
grabbed his leg and made him fall over
like he's standing by I thought he was
standing by the Indian chief grave but
maybe maybe not but he was like standing
by one grave and on the show they
actually filmed it as though there was
like I don't know like a mole or like a
I don't know like like a Tremors thing
like one of the graboids or whatever
like underneath the grass and he's kind
of like like that and he like knocks him
over but he says in the interview that
he said it felt like something grabbed
his leg and it made him fall over and
then like he looks down there was
nothing there so but he doesn't like he
falls over and the dudes are like what
the [ __ ] he's passed or whatever but he
doesn't like tell them hey I think
somebody like grabbed my leg because
they said that they didn't really tell
each other because they experienced some
things like separately but they didn't
really tell each other what they saw
until like later on you know what I mean
so he didn't tell anybody that he
thought that he somebody grabbed his leg
he's just like oh whatever I just
tripped or whatever
so they get to the mausoleum and then
they start like [ __ ] around
knocking on it and so forth they wanted
to like provoke whatever was in there so
John the the Freddy cat one he starts
getting nervous and like mad at the guys
messing with him he's like [ __ ] you guys
I'm going back to the car like he gets
all like I like the actor they got to
play him in this one he doesn't seem
like like the real guy doesn't he just
seems like kind of like just a high
school jock type of dude
um and then but the one that they after
they got to play him was kind of like he
seemed a little bit hostile and it's
like I don't know I just thought it was
like really really funny so he starts
going back to the car because he's like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] isn't it so then like
Nick starts following him and he's like
man I'm sorry you know we were just
[ __ ] with you or whatever so then he
gets him to come back so Christian the
one with the guy with the glasses he's
already sitting on top of the mausoleum
so the other two guys like climb up on
there as well so they're sitting on
there
so Nick says they're just sitting there
shooting the [ __ ] like talking about
like oh this girl she likes you man she
wants your body blah blah they're just
like talking about all that kind of crap
and he said that he started getting this
really creepy feeling that nobody wanted
them there but again was trying to like
pretend he wasn't scared because these
are teenage boys so they're just kind of
like well I can't like show any
vulnerability or say that I'm scared of
anything so they have to like just make
jokes and like pretend that they're not
afraid but he said he was really scared
like he he felt like something was like
watching him and didn't want him there
and at this point Christian kind of
looks down at where they're sitting and
he says that he noticed a big crack in
the middle of the roof of the mausoleum
which like going long ways like across
the mausoleum uh but he's pretty sure
was not there before
so Nick and Christian are like what the
[ __ ] like they jump off like to
investigate
uh but John is still sitting there and
he kind of looks down at the crack going
huh that's really weird and then
suddenly he gets pushed off apparently
like poop like he gets pushed off
now of course he initially is like what
the [ __ ] you guys doing like you know
what I mean like he thinks they did it
even though they're both standing like
in front of him so obviously they
couldn't have done it and then he thinks
oh well maybe somebody else like a
friend another friend of ours like came
to the cemetery is like [ __ ] around
and like pushed me off and so he's like
looking around but he doesn't see
anybody
and then they're like what the [ __ ] you
would you fall off or something like
that he's like no something pushed me
and then the other two guys kind of look
at each other and they're all wigged out
because as I mentioned earlier they
specifically did not tell him that
that's what the Dare was that you were
supposed to sit on top of the mausoleum
and then it goes to push you off they
said that they didn't tell him that so
the fact that he was like yeah something
pushed me off the mausoleum they were
like oh well then it's got to be real
because we didn't tell him you know what
I mean
so John at this point is like yeah again
[ __ ] this [ __ ] so he goes back to the
car he is not having it Zack Center says
I love this episode
he's got those cute boys in his Zack
that's what it is it's just your
attraction it's your attraction to these
young men
this one was
I kind of love the way the actor playing
Nick and also the real Nick that they
had on the episode they really looked
like I mean they looked there was some
real like Hot Topic energy going on
there like early too like mid-2000s like
Hot Topic energy I was feeling it yeah
and I I remember that they they were
very similar the casting was pretty good
for most of them it was actually it was
actually they did do they did do a good
job on this one like I said sometimes I
know they have a particular stable of
actors that they use so it's like
sometimes they can't get real clothes
but they do try it seems like they do
try to get right it's a fun episode it
isn't a stereotypical haunting episode
like I said it's almost like a little
greatest hits album but it's it's it's
good yeah yeah
better than a Billy Bean episode
although those might be fun to talk
about too we're going to talk about it I
think like I feel like we're just
incredible I think that we did an
episode about I can't remember like what
the first one it was the one about Bill
it was the one that when he was a kid
when he was when he was a kid and then
he moved back to it later or something
like that I'm pretty sure we did enough
the first Billy Bean episode when he was
talking about when he was a kid I was
more credible than uh the stuff that
came out of him later on with the people
that he knew and was working but that
was why that was why I wanted to kind of
interview him subtly online
because he sounded like uh that sounded
credible I think maybe something did
happen with him on that first one but
the other stuff that he was behind I
would say no I think he started to go
down the Ed and Lorraine war and path
well you know maybe that's where the
money was that's where the money was
probably I guess and it's like you know
you want to make money doing that so
right gotta do what you got to do I
guess not gonna I don't know
I mean well that's what I mean it's like
I don't begrudge people making money but
I don't really think you should do it by
peddling [ __ ] you got to have
quality control yeah you can't just say
yeah I was attacked by [ __ ] sobec so
okay yeah yeah well and the thing about
it too and the the thing that kind of
pisses me off about like people like the
Warrens and stuff like that is that you
know they might actually like somebody
that might call them like actually
thinking they might help it's like I'm
like you're kind of like exploiting
people Yeah by you know you're saying
you're helping them you're not really
helping and then you're gonna jump on
the Demon Bag bandwagon and then you're
just kind of like taking advantage of
like their story and it's like maybe
they need some other kind of help and
like none of you guys so I don't know I
just that's that's what bothers me about
it I think
so all right so uh yeah so John again is
just kind of like [ __ ] this [ __ ] and he
starts going back to the car uh so Nick
follows him but Christian is like oh
[ __ ] man like the Dare it it really
happened like he actually did get pushed
off of there he's like maybe I'll see
some other [ __ ] so he's like I'm gonna
go walk around and see if I can like see
some other ghosts and whatnot
so it's then implied that while John is
walking back to the car I'm not really
sure how big the cemetery is it looks
like a pretty good-sized Cemetery like
when they showed it at the end
um so John's walking back to the car and
he it's implied that he saw somebody
like just quickly I don't think he got a
good look at them but it's like it
looked like a figure going behind one of
the tombstones because he said Oh I
thought it was just like Christian I
thought he's just like [ __ ] around
like just playing a prank or whatever
and at this point like Nick was on there
and he says well I got really nervous
because like the three of us had like
split up at this point
um because it's like you I wasn't really
sure it was gonna happen and we were
kind of getting weirded out so John gets
back to the car and Nick goes back to
get Christians like yeah maybe we should
just go this is probably not a good idea
so he's gonna go back and get Christian
so they can leave
so while he's on his way back to find
wherever the [ __ ] Christian went to he
said that he heard kids giggling
and he said he got weirded out because
it's like look it's really late at night
I think like he looked at his watch and
it was like I don't know like 11
something or midnight or something like
that and it was Halloween night but you
know he's like uh you know there there
shouldn't be kids like but there really
wasn't anywhere for kids to be like
walking around like around this Cemetery
so he's like there really shouldn't be
any kids like laughing around here and
then he said he got the feeling that
someone was watching him
and then started seeing like Shadows
kind of figures like out of the corners
of his eye he just said he didn't see
anybody like but he's just like shadows
out of the corner of the eye type of
thing
so then John who's still on his way back
to the car it's a long way you guys
um he falls over in I think the same
spot where Nick fell at the beginning
like where the where the mole of the
graboids like came up under the grass
and like knocked him over earlier or
where uh you know the the dad from
Father's Day like in Creep Show like
came out of the Grave or whatever I got
my cake but yeah so there was that so he
falls over and I think it was the same
spot I'm not entirely sure
then he looks at and this seemed like
just weird enough to be true I don't
know I don't know I just I don't know if
these guys are telling the truth or not
but this seems like a really weird
detail so he says he fell over and then
he got up and then he was like looking
at one Tombstone and it had one name and
one set of dates on it that said I don't
remember that it was like it was a
woman's name and I don't remember what
the dates were
but then he kind of like hears some
wrestling or some [ __ ] and like he looks
behind him like that and then he looks
back at the grave and now it has a
different name like a man's name and a
different set of dates on it so I was
like that seems random doesn't it that
like you would just so I don't know I
don't know if I believe that or not but
it just seems like something that you
wouldn't necessarily like think to make
up I'm not really sure
um then he says that
uh he sees well I don't know like on
this show they showed this
um it's implied that he sees two figures
standing there I couldn't really tell I
think one of them was like supposed to
be the Indian chief I don't know the
[ __ ] the other one was uh it looked like
a woman so it's implied that he sees
that but I don't think he said that like
in the interview he did say the [ __ ]
about like the looking at back at the
grave and it being like a different name
and different dates on it but I don't
think he said that he saw like people
you know what I mean because you gotta
watch they'll they'll stretch the truth
a little bit and it's entirely possible
that when they did the interviews
because I know they probably interview
these people for several hours and it's
entirely possible that the people said
something about Z like yeah I turned
around and saw these two figures or
whatever and then they put that in the
show but then they didn't have the
footage of them saying that but I'm
always like really skeptical because
sometimes like I said they'll try to
make it scarier and I'm like well he
didn't say that though he didn't say he
saw that so I'm just saying
all right so John runs into Nick again
uh real Nick says whatever was showing
itself wanted us to leave that's what he
said so I'm assuming maybe they actually
did see apparitions because he said
whatever was showing itself I'm just but
he did say that
meanwhile Christian is wandering around
in the oldest section of the cemetery
which is the Pioneer section
now he said that some of the graves had
a weird blue what he called a blue gleam
around them I don't know how many graves
it was like on the show I think it was
three of them like next to each other
that were like glowing kind of blue but
he didn't say how many it was he just
said some of the oldest ones like had
this weird blue gleam on them and he
said it was really creepy so then he's
looking at him going what the [ __ ] and
he's like touching him and whatnot and
then he turns around and he says he saw
this row of like really odd shaped
tombstones he said there were seven of
them and they were like really tall and
narrow with kind of ovals at the top
that sort of looked like heads so it
kind of looked like
it almost looked like people's
Silhouettes like but no arms or legs or
anything like that but it looked like
you know like a chest and a head sort of
thing and they were like long and narrow
so then he turns back to the glowy
graves
and then turns back around and sees that
now there are only five of the narrow
tombstones behind him like two of them
have disappeared
and he said I was sure that there had
been seven of them before but now like a
second later there was only five of them
so it's then implied that he saw a
figure walking behind a grave and he
kind of follows it and and he starts
calling out like hey I know somebody's
there or something like that and then he
sees two ghost kids like a boy and a
girl standing right in front of him
now again I was skeptical but he did say
they were standing right in front of me
I think that's pretty much the quote
what he said
um and he also said I was afraid that
they would start coming toward me and I
didn't know what I would do if that
happened so I don't know if he said that
there was kids but on the show they
showed it was kid so I'm imagining that
it was that's what it was but he did say
that he saw them standing in front of
him so there's that so he saw ghost kids
so at this point like Christian comes
out of the cemetery
and uh Nick and John are already waiting
for him in the car Christian they
they're like we immediately into like
knew something he'd seen some [ __ ]
because he didn't talk he was like
acting really weird he just started the
car and backed up and he's like they
just like [ __ ] left and didn't say
anything so the other two guys are kind
of trying to get him to tell him what
they saw but he won't say anything
so as I mentioned nobody told anybody
anything that they had seen like
individually
um until later on
Christian said that the reason that he
didn't say anything to them was that if
they told them that they'd seen the same
things that he saw then he said that it
would be quote too much for him to
handle like I said it would it would
make it real I guess like if you if it's
just you saying it you can be like well
I'm nuts or whatever but like if you say
to somebody else they're like holy [ __ ]
I saw the same thing they're like oh
[ __ ] ghosts are real we're in trouble I
don't know I'll tell you
when I was up at Mammoth and then we
could all agree that some [ __ ] moved I
was a big relief to me
I was like yeah this is real
it's not my imagination
you know yeah I'm not really sure I
think I'd feel better yeah you feel a
lot better because it's like I don't run
I don't want to be crazy and seeing [ __ ]
and then all of a sudden you now have
like uh some kind of a [ __ ] foreign
threat outside the group you're like
there's something in here that's a weird
[ __ ] weird there's that that's a weird
sensation too
Danny Rowling said the same thing
happens in Blair Witch 2 with the
gravestones changing oh [ __ ] I forgot
about that okay now where did when did
Blair Witch 2 come out because maybe
that's where they got the idea then I've
seen Blair Witch too but it's been a
long time I know the first player which
was 1999. yeah you're talking about the
scene where there was five and then
there was three either that or and then
there's three well no because remember
there was a thing too where the
gravestone where he loves the Graystone
and like the names and dates were
different
so if a Blair Witch 2 came out before
this then maybe that's where they got
the idea then
oh man I can't remember when that movie
see here's the thing 2000 yeah so maybe
they saw that movie and they were like
oh that's a good idea here's the thing I
had totally forgotten about that if
you're not there at the time
there's no way of knowing exactly what
happened you just gotta take these
stories that face it out of you sure
well that's what we're doing that's just
having a good time right yeah I'm not
I'm not making any kind of statements
yeah I'm not making a judgment on it
yeah you're right you know this is just
what they said if I was there maybe it
wouldn't maybe it wouldn't have seemed
that way to me or maybe I wouldn't say
the same thing but like I said that's
what some of these some of these
episodes of The Haunting well actually
all of them
uh you gotta kind of look deeper you
know what I mean what actually happened
is there a difference between what the
Witnesses are saying and then what the
haunting show is talking about that
that's you know so
we said I get that they're just trying
to make a creepy show you know I respect
that yeah I respect that yeah but you
just gotta like come at it from that
it's like well right this isn't like you
know the gospel truth right that they're
just like making something creamy if you
ask me the [ __ ] granddaddy of all of
these from this series is a haunting of
Summerwind
and then when you look at the details it
was a best episode but when you look at
the details it's a lot more
understandable when you actually look at
the real photographs of that house
that that's a
did something happen there
Maybe
but a lot of the [ __ ] that they reported
in that episode could be easily
explained as something else like that
the house I kind of feel like that's
true of every episode like I kind of
feel like a lot of this stuff even well
[ __ ] I mean even we've done episodes
where they said oh this happened and
that happened and I was like yeah but if
you were there at the time like that
could have easily been right that could
have been explained you know what I mean
yeah
so um Danny Rowling said not many people
noticed the gravestones changing in the
film because you have to rewind it to
catch all the hidden stuff in the film
reposit well [ __ ] now I'm gonna have to
because I think I have that on DVD
somewhere I'm pretty sure I remember
buying it like a long time ago Blair
Witch too okay you know and I know I
haven't seen it in a long time but I
remember actually really liking Blair
Witch too don't hate
um I kind of feel like a lot of people
didn't like it but it's not really found
footage they kind of went meta with it
but I don't know I was I I kind of liked
it but I haven't seen it a long time so
maybe it sucks but I remember liking it
at the time
uh Danny Rowling said yes get Tom to
watch it okay
look Blair Witch too man I don't like
Blair Witch one well Blair Witch 2 is
totally different though okay it's
totally different like it's like I said
it goes more meta it's not found footage
so that's it's not the same it's better
than the first one in my opinion well
okay I'm glad that you said that because
I thought I was crazy I don't know if
it's necessarily the better it's
different than the first one but I
actually really liked Blair Witch too
it's called Book of Shadows
um and a lot of people really don't like
it so I'm always like I'm always
reluctant to like share that opinion
because people like what are you [ __ ]
high that's a terrible movie but like I
said I haven't seen in a long time it
might it might be terrible but I I
remember liking it at the time all right
so uh okay so where where was I so they
get home now Nick says he did more
research about the cemetery afterward
now the mausoleum apparently is the
burial place of several children who
died of polio that's what they said on
the show anyway
um he doesn't find any evidence that the
ceiling of it was cracked though because
remember I said well like when they were
sitting on it like he said oh there was
a crack and we were sure it wasn't there
before so he was looking for other
photos of it online and he's like it
doesn't look like it's cracked so you
know uh so then they kind of do a little
bit of a little bit of cheat I'm gonna
say they do it's not exactly a cheat
because Nick said he did have a dream
like this but they do a dream sequence
okay which you don't usually see too
much on a haunting so you have a dream
sequence knit dreams now he apparently
like I said did really dream something
like this so it's not entirely a cheat
that he went back to the cemetery by
himself and saw the crack in the
mausoleum like on the top and it was
like glow in blue like this blue like
glowing out of it and heard all kind of
like howling and wind blowing and
screaming and [ __ ] like that and then he
like runs like hell away from the
mausoleum and then tripped in the same
spot
and then he said he felt like when he
woke up that he felt like the dream was
the ghost telling him not to come back
there that's what he said
so the next day at school he tells the
other two guys pretty much everything he
saw and experienced including the dream
and then they all start opening up about
everything that they saw too like you
know it's like hey I saw two ghost kids
and hey because they hadn't told each
other that previously uh John the
chicken [ __ ] one said I don't know
I don't know what else to call it all
right I don't know what else to call him
I'm just still laughing at about the
north branchi thing but um he says I
don't he says and I wrote this down I
don't know what would have happened if
we would have stayed there that night
and he said he called The Experience
scary and traumatic
so there's that
so then they show like while all they're
all in the parking lot of the high
school like talking about man I saw
ghost kids and all this other [ __ ] then
the random girl from the this was such a
long time ago you might not even
remember from the first part of like the
framing part of the episode with the
first three people that were sitting on
the mausoleum okay so that random girl
who we never find out what her name is
so I don't even know if she represents a
real person or not but she walks past
them and it's implied that she overheard
them talking like ooh haunted cemetery
I'm all about that let's do that so now
her and her two friends one of whom
actually does appear on the show who
like I said his name is Corbin Van Buren
like they said any relation to Martin
Van Buren perhaps Corbin Bernardino's
great great great grandson
so him and his two friends who were
never named oh look Pookie's on the show
ah pokey's on the show she's like oh
okay I will accept some she loves face
love
back down you wanna go back down you can
go back there she's like okay yeah she
likes head butts yeah head butts and
[ __ ] rubbing like when I get when I
get into when I kind of settle down in
the bed in the evening like to watch TV
and she'll come in the room and I'll be
like head butt Pookie and she jumps up
on the bed and she comes over and she
goes Boop it's the only cat I've ever
known that doesn't shy away from your
face yeah she likes Face yeah you sit
there you can kiss her and she's like
leaning into it yeah she's like all
right yeah
yeah I like stick my face in her face
all the time she loves it
uh yeah most cats don't like that
they're like get the [ __ ] away from me
human gross yeah but but yeah so so yeah
Corbin Van Buren and his two random
friends who are not on the show and are
not named even though they're actors on
the show uh they said okay well we we
wanted to do the same thing like the
shit's on it now they didn't go I don't
think it was Halloween I think they said
it was like November 2006. so it's like
you know a little more than a year later
so they're gonna go and do the same
thing so they're walking toward the
mausoleum and they said that they heard
Twigs snapping behind them and like
leaves rustling like somebody was
following them that's what he said it
sounded like somebody was following them
so they check out the Indian chief grave
first
um and as I mentioned Corbin said there
was a legend that people had seen the
Indian chief uh walking around the
cemetery in his kind of like headdress
and all that
so while they're looking at the grave
they see this figure walking around and
initially they just think it's like a
person like somebody's in the graveyard
with them like oh maybe somebody you
know a family member like came to put
flowers on a grave or something they're
like yeah but it's the middle of the
night so that would be a little bit
weird and I'm like yeah but you
[ __ ] are there so maybe you
know maybe it's some other teenagers
hold on Veronica Z's in there talking
about some of these uh
investigate TV investigators you know
um
a lot of times these investigators are
more actors than anything else I mean
there was one of them that I thought
there might be something to the
[ __ ] for a while and that was
the guy from Paranormal you and then as
time went on no it dude it's a [ __ ]
jump and he was also like a charlatan
uh so you got to watch those television
investigators you know there's a reason
why they're television investigators
they're they're meant to fulfill a
[ __ ] Market niche they're kind of an
artificial product it's just the way
corporations are you know
well the thing about it
too that it's just like people that turn
up on like a lot of reality shows yeah
it's like a lot of those people are just
like actors or comedians or something
like that that are trying to get their
big break which like I said I'm not
begrudging them that
um you know but they're you know they're
trying to get famous yeah there's
nothing reality about any of the reality
no a lot of yeah most of them are
entertainers right like I said they're
usually actors or Comedians and we know
because we know that those people that
do that right like uh and they're trying
to get on there our friend Jacob Angel
is
again he's from Colombia and he's a
Colombian
vampire dude I've shown pictures on
another [ __ ] show he was married to a
friend of ours for a while and he would
show up on South American
talk shows their versions of Jerry
Springer to pretend to be some chick's
boyfriend and the families met all fake
yeah all [ __ ] fake and he was a
suspension artist and self-mutilator and
all that kind of weird he looked like
the devil you know he was but he was the
[ __ ] greatest guy you'd ever [ __ ]
made he was really cool he was a um me
and him had a lot in common he was uh
ex-columbian army sniper from a scout
unit and I was from a scout unit too and
his older brother was a Colombian army
officer that [ __ ] was involved in a
bunch of [ __ ] during their Civil Wars
and everything but you look at the guy
and you would think that he was just
like something that from the bowels of
hell no he's a military man he just knew
how to [ __ ]
push the right buttons in you get up
he's cool dude like I said don't believe
anything on TV he's a really nice guy
nice guy yeah she he did Jenny's tattoo
yeah he was actually at our house tattoo
yeah yeah he came where we're doing yeah
I'll pull up a picture of him
go ahead Jim uh all right where was I
yeah so they think somebody else is in
the graveyard with them yeah somebody's
just here like uh you know they're
coming to get you Barbara whatever so
then they go and sit on the mausoleum
now they apparently see a bunch of
figures around the muscle I don't think
they I don't think he said this but they
showed this on the show
so they see like three figures standing
around the mausoleum like it looks like
the chief the two kids so it's four
figures okay I can't I can't math sorry
and uh you know the Christians are
earlier and this random woman who nobody
ever mentions so you know poor ghost and
then all three of them get pushed off
one by one like boop boop boop like they
all get pushed off
so at that point even though that's what
they came for they're like we're getting
the [ __ ] out of here so they beat cheeks
uh and they're like yeah the ghost
didn't want us here so we got the [ __ ]
out no poop what's the matter tearing
[ __ ] up Oh I thought she was like yeah
that's okay like I said I put the I put
the shitty books on the bottom so she
could like
look how big look how busy she is yeah
she's just very busily like scratching
all of the paper out so uh so yeah so
they leave the cemetery
and then they they drive away and they
stop on the side of the road and
basically like pull over and then they
all pile out of the car like what the
[ __ ] was that like what happened now the
girl I don't know what her name is but
she sees like a bunch of scratches on
her arms like because I think the other
one is just like what's on your arms and
she looks and apparently there's like
all these big scratches I don't know
what they really look like in real life
but um what I know that was good oh okay
I'm just always afraid you're gonna like
interrupt in the middle are you afraid
that whatever yeah you know I'm just
kind of like
foreign
there's Jacob right there at the wings
if you can see it
that's him
that's him he's been a bunch of
television shows all throughout
Colombian Central America and South
America and so he's a little celebrity
that they have down there be a good guy
and he did Jenny's tattoo
Danny Rowling said my cousin played a
stripper on a Halloween episode of The
Jerry Springer Show yeah yeah that's
what I mean I kind of feel like I don't
know if like people really did believe
that all those people were real but most
of them were like I said they were
sackers that's him without his uh
costume
okay all right so that's that's our
that's that's Jake
and Colombia's Gothic as [ __ ] their
architecture [ __ ] rocks
Danny Rowling said he looks like a
character from Mortal Kombat yeah yeah
he looks like a monster but like I said
he's like one of the nicest dudes and
he's a great tattoo artist he is yeah
yeah he did this in I think what did it
take 10 hours yeah about that he sat
there and [ __ ] did that in our in our
house
that's a well he did the outline and
then he's like well because normally
they would do the outline and then the
color I'm just like well you're here so
you might as well do it
I wonder so we sat there for 10 hours I
wanted to get my [ __ ] sleeve done he
says yeah I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do
this and that and this and that but then
he he had to go back to Columbia yeah
ran out of time he moved away yeah yeah
I wanted him to do well I had a whole
back piece I wanted him yeah you know oh
well
um but yeah so all right what happened
all right so yeah so the girl has
scratches all over her arms Corbin said
it looked like an animal had clawed her
I don't know like how they showed it
like looking pretty severe like in the
show but I don't really know then Corbin
says he gets a sudden pain in his leg he
said as though someone was stabbing
through it with a knife on the show they
showed like this big bloody wound there
like he pulls it up like it's on his uh
Shin or something they're not his shin
but like his calf and uh so I don't know
what it actually looked like because he
just said in the interview like it's it
felt like somebody was stabbing through
it with a knife
um and he said yeah it didn't look
anything like we had just run through
like and got scratched by branches or
nothing like that and so basically they
got the [ __ ] out of there and never came
back and then they just had a little
kodo where it said oh Corbin read some
accounts about the cemetery from Chad's
website from later and now says yeah I
believe all that [ __ ] because you know
we experienced it as well so I found
this website called
wisconsinfrights.com I think it is and
they talked a little bit about Dartford
Cemetery which like I said it seems like
a pretty famous haunted place
um but yeah so they're kind of talking
about I don't know they went on a little
bit of the history
uh about it like
I guess before there was a cemetery
there uh you know it's good old Native
American bear I don't even know if it
was Native American Berry burial ground
I think it was just like a sacred Place
uh according to this website it said it
was a mystical place that seemed to have
no bottom
where they gathered to pay homage to the
spirit who dwells beneath the water
and it was kind of like a water spirit
kind of played like hanging out there uh
oh that's right the you know the um the
grave that had the the Indian chief you
know guy on it that Indian cheese name
in real life because I saw the actual
real grave his name was Chief High
knocker yeah okay chief High knocker and
it says that on there uh it says he's
knocking high on his nickname derived
from the stovepipe Hat he always wore
okay yeah right so why didn't they call
Abe Lincoln that I don't know because he
had the same kind of hat Chief High
knocker I don't know that sounds dirty I
think we're missing well we're missing
the context I guess so yeah but it's
just like so I guess like he died in
1911 and he was the last uh Winnebago
that's the tribe that it was like the
chief to rule the area so he got buried
there and his grave is like super it's
not as creepy as the one they show on
the show that one like I said was more
like a horror movie looking grave the
one in real life is creepy but it looks
like it they didn't mean for it to be
creepy it just turned out like that you
know what I'm saying yeah um but I and
it does and I'm pretty sure it does say
Chief High knocker on it which I don't
know why that made me laugh so hard but
I was like why would you want your
nickname on your gravestone though
like what was his actual name um Chief
High knocker
I wouldn't want Chief High knocker on my
gravestone just saying uh but yeah so
apparently
um I guess there's like a a boulder
there too and yeah the the site calls it
an unusual gravestone it is it's like
it's really really weird looking now the
mausoleum that they're talking about
even though on the show I don't know if
it's true or not like on the show they
said that the mausoleum and they kind of
made a big deal about
um that there was a bunch of kids that
had died of polio and they were in there
and so they like when um one of the kids
like has a dream about it there's like
all these little kids like laying in
coffins and like their eyes open and
[ __ ] like that and it's like super
creepy but I don't know like it has the
actual Mausoleum I saw a picture of it
and on one side of it there's like a um
like a little thing that has names on it
now it says Jackson Walker but I don't
know if that's someone's name like their
name was Jackson Walker or if that's two
last names you know what I mean like I
don't know if it's like two
interconnected families who are like the
Jacksons and the Walkers and they're all
buried in this one Mausoleum because
it's not big but it looks like you could
put like several
bodies in there so I'm not really
knowing like if anybody is like from
Wisconsin and has been here like let me
know because I'm kind of curious about
it but so I don't know if it's kids or
because here's the weird thing the
episode at the beginning at the
beginning it said that the mausoleum was
the final I think it said the final
resting place of some of the cities or
the town's Pioneers but then later on it
says no it was a bunch of kids that died
of polio I'm like well which is it I
mean it could be all of them I guess but
I don't know
Zach says have you guys ever thought of
a show about famous building fires
uh you know what
um no but that's actually like kind of a
good idea like what like maybe like the
the Triangle Shirtwaist fire or the
Chicago Fire that you know Miss
O'Leary's cow or whatever
I mean yeah that might that might be
good
we could do that I'll write it down I'll
put it in one of the polls and we'll see
how it how it does
we'll see how it does
block frog said my cat head butts me too
yeah I really yeah she she doesn't
always do it like sometimes she fakes me
out like she'll jump up on the bed and
she'll come up like that and I'll be
like hey butt head butt and then the
last second she's like nope and then she
turns around like ah
no head butt denied but but sometimes
she'll do it and she jumps up on my desk
at headbutts that's like really really
funny she really does kind of like like
to get up in everyone's face
um let's have her own toy and chased it
but she picked up a little red mouse toy
that she hadn't threw it and then ran
after you're funny you were hilarious
she's like well you guys aren't doing it
I have to do everything myself around
here catch it catch it
yeah
you should have got her on camera
I know I threw the through the mouth she
caught well she was before we started
the show we were laughing because she um
she not only throws her own toys which
is hysterical yeah she like Picks Them
Up in her little house and goes and
nobody chases them but she also does
she'll pick him up and then just kind of
like manipulate them around and I said
it's almost like Tom said it's almost
like a little kid like a little kid with
like a toy car or something like making
a move like boom so like she does that
like she just kind of moves it around
like it's walking she's making it walk
she's making it walk they're little toy
animals so she picks them up like that
and she hits him with her claws and goes
he's like look it's running around yeah
and then she might throw it afterwards
and then kind of run after yeah
she's smart
yeah she's got lots of little mouses in
here yeah
lots of little mouthies and she also has
like kind of like a little stuffed cat
and a little stuffed like uh Dracula
that makes like kind of little crumply
sound
uh did y'all ever do the Great Fire of
London I don't think we ever did but
yeah famous fires I'm just kind of
thinking yeah that was like a big deal
sure I had these shows up says hello how
you doing Sarah
I'm thinking London the Chicago Fire it
was all kind of like famous fires that's
actually probably a good idea for a show
we got so much we got so much of that
damn crab salad
oh we still got some of that got a [ __ ]
ton of crab salad I'm gonna make it like
a crab salad wrap
all right like on a burrito thing with
uh I got I got green peppers out of the
out of the garden oh my goodness sound
good yeah it does what else would go in
there uh uh
you don't like raw onion so I can't put
that in there well I like it it just
gives me really bad it hurts you
make like a vegetable crab salad wrap
yeah that sounds good okay varica Z says
my cat does exactly the same thing
she'll even play tag with them tag it
with her paw turns around like are you
gonna chase me she does that with
Furniture as well she'll Tag Furniture
right away and run away from it like
come on chase me
[Laughter]
well she tries to get Tom to chase her
own yeah I chase her sometimes yeah yeah
she likes to she yeah she likes you to
chase her like if you don't she'll kind
of like run up on you like kind of grab
your leg and then like look at you and
then like run away like
he's like come on yeah [ __ ] chase me
yeah
he's funny she is very funny and she
doesn't hide anywhere she'll run into
another room and then [ __ ] lay on her
back and roll her like though
with her little bellies take it yeah and
her little paws don't do it oh my God I
Surrender yeah oh my God she's hilarious
like I said it's like it's like having
it's like having a kid but better
the kid that can reach the ceiling that
see that's Jackson Galaxy I love Jackson
Galaxy like I subscribed to him on
YouTube but um that was one of the
coolest things that he ever said he said
I think that people like they think oh
they get a cat and it's like low
maintenance
um no they're like having a cat he's
like it's like having a toddler that can
reach the ceiling and I'm like yeah
that's she's over there right now trying
to find accurate [ __ ] up what are you
gonna do like I said middle of the night
if you weren't here at the beginning of
the show middle of the night not last
night but last night or the night before
last like two nights ago she climbed
into Tom's lower bathroom like the
bathroom cabinet because she knows how
to open the cabinet doors she can open
them and go in there and hide and uh she
went in there and threw out a can of
spray paint yeah and it was like it was
four o'clock in the morning I think it
was four o'clock in the morning because
I woke up and I heard
like really close I was like what the
[ __ ] is that and like I run out and she
pops out the bathroom and like with her
little tail wagon like what yeah I
didn't do anything I didn't I don't know
what that what was that noise Mommy I
don't know like she was like acting all
innocent
it was [ __ ] funny but she always she
knows when she did something bad or like
when it made noise I think she
she does stuff without realizing how
noisy it's gonna be and then when it
makes a bunch of noise she's like oh
[ __ ] yeah and so then like she tries to
act all casually play it off like she's
like I don't know what was that I don't
know it wasn't me yeah it always was her
though always uh Danny Rowling said what
did Tom think of this episode Legend
Trippers what did you think of Legend
Trippers in general uh I thought it was
entertaining uh you had a bunch of
bunch of bunch of stories about you know
what was happening in that particular
area did I think that they were
authentic or you know or you know I
think they were the real thing I don't
know if maybe that's what he's asking me
it's hard to say I wasn't there
I want to go sit on this Mausoleum yeah
I went there I haven't seen any I
haven't seen phenomena like described in
this
uh
it's pretty typical
in terms of like you know Legends Legend
Tripper yeah that's that's a good way to
describe the [ __ ] are tripping
telling these Legends
okay but that's just the this is the
nature of a lot of these kind of stories
seeing is believing
I'd have to be there like I said if I
went and sat on the mausoleum in some
like invisible [ __ ] push me off
yeah it's more likely it's teenage boys
[ __ ] with each other's minds I'm just
kind of like I had to be there doubting
that that would happen because I really
like I said I'm very skeptical right so
it's like and honestly I like cemeteries
I would be like sitting there in the
middle so I'd probably sit there all
night and nothing would happen yeah and
then the other ones you're driving down
the street some old man's out in the out
in the road and it turns out it's the
son of some chick that was run over here
years ago it's the [ __ ] ghost to him
it's the dead the dead it's upset the
dad the ghost of the Dead
that's more ghost story stuff
I love those but I don't necessarily
think they're true though I don't know
if they're true or not they're just fun
stories some of them are just stories I
like urban legends I like urban legends
yeah I'm interested in them because I've
seen weird [ __ ] yeah yeah they're
paranormal but I haven't seen that kind
of stuff you know but
like I said you'd have to be there if
I'd have to be there and have to see it
you know but I'm not gonna discount it
and uh yeah I'm I'm gonna say it's most
likely that that is not true
but I'm going to say 100 that like it's
impossible I have to I'd have to see it
well and I feel like there's a lot of we
might have talked about because I think
we did a show a long time ago about like
did you do 100 show about like haunted
cemeteries and [ __ ] because I mean I
mean I've been to St Augustine that's
the the uh Huguenot Cemetery there is
like supposedly haunted I've never seen
anything in there but there's a couple
actually there's a couple haunted uh
cemeteries there they're creepy I'm not
saying that
um they're really old but
I don't you know I've never seen
anything in there particularly but
what's that one um
[ __ ] is it around here I can't remember
but there's one that has like the
Devil's Chair is that called The Devil's
Chair it's like this brick it's like a
really weird
um
thing that somebody had built like so
people could like hang out at their
grave I guess but it's like a brick
chair thing and apparently they call it
the Devil's Chair and if you go there
and leave I love how specific this is if
you go there and leave a full closed can
of beer
on the chair then when you go back in
the morning the can will be empty but it
won't be open so like the ghost can
drink all the beer out of the can so I
guess he shotguns it out of like a
little bitty tiny hole or whatever now
Jenny mentioned huguenots if you're not
if you're not American you probably
don't know what Huguenot is maybe a lot
of Americans don't know what Huguenot is
in American history
you know they're always talking about
Plymouth Rock and the pilgrims that came
over and then eventually you know
through the colonies
America was born
through these religious dissidents that
runner from Europe
well
a lot of people kind of forget that
Florida is older than the United States
far older this is French and Spanish
territory and it was
uh you know it had changed hands a
couple times
there were people like the pilgrims that
came here in the 1500s long time before
the uh the the the the the British
pilgrims and they were coming from
France and they were the huguenots the
huguenots were a lot like the
they were a lot like the uh
the Puritans in his in in a certain way
they were kind of Protestants they were
like French Protestants
um so in some ways
you could say the the huguenots are kind
of like prototype Americans
prototype American colonists so that's
what that's that's what that well like I
said a bunch of them are buried uh right
over in Saint Augustine there's a whole
it even says Huguenot Cemetery yeah the
huguenots ended up because
France didn't join the union until the
1800s
very early 1800s it was a I was 18 20 18
what Florida you mean Florida you said
France I'm in Florida yeah Florida
didn't join the union I think till 8 18
15 18 18 some around 1820 or something
like that yeah I feel like it was 1820
though yeah it was uh Andrew Jackson it
kind of was purchased after after the
Seminole Wars and stuff but like I said
that's what's cool about going to like
St Augustine because that's been there
since the 1500s yeah like a lot of that
stuff's been there since you have these
[ __ ]
North and [ __ ]
saying these damn Hispanics moving into
the country they were here long before
the United States [ __ ] friend
Florida Florida was
[ __ ] Hispanic
Pirates yeah and Pirates yeah and the
further south you went the more it was
kind of like something out of them the
Caribbean you know and his long predates
the United States
so it's not like they're moving into our
territory we moved into their territory
the same with the Southwest you know
what I mean they were there long before
we were okay
we just they were they all got a next or
purchased so people need to check their
history you know it's [ __ ] funny
Hispanics have always been here
they've always been America well like I
said go to yeah go to St Augustine
there's a huge yeah Fort there that was
built by the Spanish yeah
um actually like some of the stuff some
of it is from the 1500s and some of it
was like added on later but it's pretty
it's pretty impressive you go through
American history and some of the [ __ ]
greatest [ __ ] war heroes of World War
II pilots and everything [ __ ]
Hispanic it could go back to World War
One you know goes back to [ __ ] Indian
Wars and [ __ ] you know
America North America has pretty much
always looked like this they're just
more people now but it but if you look
at the ratios it's always kind of looked
like this
Zach says so Florida is technically
haunted by Pirates badass yeah Florida I
think yeah yeah I mean Louisiana oh
everything I mean everything around like
I said the
into like pre United States Florida
history because like I said it's almost
all like it's all just those old like
Native American stuff pirate stuff yeah
old Spanish type stuff it's like it's
fascinating there was all kind of stuff
and like I said St Augustine which you
know I've been to many times I grew up
only about like 40 50 miles from there
that's like the oldest city in the
United States it was it was established
a couple centuries before you know any
of the kind of like Mainstays the same
with Mississippi and Alabama along that
Coast past Christiane Biloxi you know
Long Beach always put in those areas
before those places existed with us all
French and Spanish towns and ports even
in places like Mississippi you think
Mississippi that's some you know where
all those white rednecks can come from
no Mississippi's 30-something percent 33
black it's the blackest state in the
Union there's a lot of Irish and British
and German and people that really were
through there in French you know just
the south is Farm was always diverse
always it's just the people up north
don't understand the South
what's she doing
yeah we didn't put
no I mean I got French names you know my
middle name is French you know Francois
okay I'm gonna start calling you yeah
Francois you know so I got a French
middle name and it's just a real [ __ ]
people that come from Mississippi
Louisiana's gonna have French names in
there
just how it is and we endless we make it
a little more Anglican called Francis or
something but no they mean Francois
but uh yeah
yeah
so you know it's just uh that's just the
way the South was and always always it
was like that it'll probably always be
that way
Sarah said this is also one of my
favorite episodes talking about Legend
Trippers yeah I kind of feel like a lot
of people likes I don't know I kind of
prefer I think I prefer the more
house based ones because I'm like a big
haunted house girl but I like that they
kind of changed it up because I love
urban legends and I'm always Gonna Love
a haunted cemetery because I love
[ __ ] cemeteries so you know it was
fun that they did something different
with it this is honestly I haven't seen
every episode obviously we're gonna
we're gonna um we have if you don't know
we have like on disk we have episodes or
uh seasons one through seven we bought
season eight which I think was only six
episodes right yeah I think it was only
six episodes we bought that like online
and
eventually we'll get around to buying
the other ones like not all at once
because this would be too expensive but
I do want to see some of that I'll get
another season yeah I mean we got we
watched um the first three or four
three episodes of season eight yeah I
think I fell asleep like one before
we've seen that season we have seen them
yeah because I think we saw them when
they were live like on TV yeah because
when we saw them I was like man I've
seen this yeah but it was a long time
the quality is better than I remembered
it's just the stories are a little
weaker
yes so far this the cases are a little
yeah I mean now a couple of the episodes
well because like I said we started
watching season eight and I was like oh
some of these are good but then we got
to the mummy one and I was like are
really okay yeah and I think dude was
trolling
although if he was I mean kudos to him
for keeping a straight face because I
would not have been able to
you know
just saying
those are stories of a small Christian
church trying to make money
yeah I mean I hate to say it does really
kind of seem like that yeah The
Reptilian mummies is being attacked by a
[ __ ] is so big a [ __ ] ancient
Egyptian god and they're calling it a
demon which is an assault okay Sobek
would have been kind of subject was cool
Sobek would have been the Egyptian
version of the Andrew Angel Gabriel okay
he was uh the Nile Angel he looked after
you when you were like on the Nile so
you wouldn't get [ __ ] up and he was he
was like a crocodile God he was also
kind of like the angel of military
prowess that too so you're talking about
Gabriel he's one of the he's one of the
one of the top she's looking out for him
people say well it's a god well it was
no it was one of gods or omun's Sons so
in other words if it was one of God's
Sons Angels is what they're saying yeah
because that's what it was in uh just
because he had a crocodile head don't
hate right yeah well those were that was
a spiritual form sure it was that was
his spiritual form these were all
spirits
like I said he's putting an a he wasn't
an alligator he looked like a crocodile
because he was protecting him from
getting eaten from crocodiles when you
were in the Nile yeah exactly he's like
I can scare off the other crocodiles and
keep your ass safe so the story is
ridiculous
it's a bunch of Christians calling to
them basically the Egyptian version of
the of the Archangel Gabriel they're
calling him a demon
that is something that now that you kind
of like put it that is yeah well that's
what it is yeah it is right yeah you can
say well what about your Archangel
Gabriel is that is he a demon he carries
a sword
you know what I mean he evidently talked
to the to the Prophet Muhammad
and you don't like
Islam so does that make Gabriel a demon
they say oh no it's just they just made
that story up if you look me all those
stories are made up well yeah this is a
pet this is this is this is kind of like
the MCU this is all mythology yeah and
like I said that's no hate on the MCU or
uh religions it's not religious it's the
same thing like people just humans are
storytelling animals that's how we
understand the world like through
stories they're teaching they're
teaching morality and Rights and Wrongs
and legends all through these stories to
give you an identity it's a tribal
identity but that's not a bad thing
that's a good thing you should know your
people and where they come from and what
they believe in what they value and
those ideas spread throughout Europe and
the Middle East and it's all good if you
understand what it is you just don't
want to take it literally it's not
literal
yeah that'll get you in trouble yeah no
it's like a thousand years now they're
taking the damn Star Wars [ __ ]
Trilogy as literal you know I can
totally see what's that happening yeah
right or the MCU like the MCU a thousand
years ago like Iron Man did this then
the other side yeah a dude came from
another planet when we know this is true
because we found out there are other
planets and his name was [ __ ] call L
yeah okay and he was like super scared
of super Krypton this had to have
happened Kryptonite yeah it happened in
this place called metropolis and we all
know that Metropolis is New York so this
is true story yeah and that's what
they're doing it's exactly the same it's
exactly what they're doing it's exactly
the same yep
it's just I mean
that sounds it sounds ridiculous people
nowadays because it wasn't that long ago
like we know where Superman came from
right but call me back in a thousand
years right they're gonna tell you that
oh no an alien did come to New York
that's what they're gonna say thousands
of years ago Mrs Evans already party
said Star Trek is true not Star Wars LOL
that'd be cool I want Star Trek to be
true I want Spock to be real yeah
only the only the old Star Trek well
yeah I mean the other ones are good too
but I mean it's it's hard to beat the OG
I mean you know that that was lightning
in a bottle I'm a heretic I like [ __ ]
star [ __ ] A Star Trek Enterprise I know
and nobody seems to like that one it was
all right I liked it with shran and all
those guys okay I'm gonna get off this
one well that was Jeffrey Combs okay
what are you leaving yeah Oh I thought
you were leaving for good and I was like
well should I
should I shut the [ __ ] down you didn't
tell me to
I don't know so I guess I'll keep going
uh Danny Rowling said King Solomon is uh
sir man from Lord of the Rings yeah it's
like I said it's no shame in that it's
just that's how people
um kind of get a grip on their on the
world around them they make up stories
about it like you know and they
incorporate real things into the story
like like it just helps them like to get
a handle on it that's just kind of like
that's that's how people's brains work
we're just storytelling animals so you
know
I'm not like [ __ ] on anything
Danny Rowling said uh butt pirates
haunting asses sure
we did a whole show about Florida
Pirates did we not like not too long ago
that was a fun show to do I still
haven't finished reading that goddamn
I started reading that book
um
under the Black Flag which I actually
bought at the Pirate Museum in St
Augustine Florida and it's a good book
it's not it's not um exclusively about
Florida Pirates it's actually more about
um the reality of pirates versus like
the movie version of pirates you know
what I mean and and like where are
um where our kind of uh all the stuff
about Parts like having wooden legs and
parrots and stuff like that like where
that comes from so it's kind of like
that it's like a comparison of like
fictional Pirates versus real ones and
then it has like some real history in it
too but it's actually like really good
if you want to read it if you're if
you're really into like Pirates or
pirate lore it's actually like a really
it's one of the best ones that I've ever
read about that
um but yeah I haven't I've only got like
through the first few chapters because
I've been reading like a bunch of other
horror stuff to review so I haven't like
got to it yet but
yeah
I kind of want him to come back so I can
like go to the bathroom
Danny Rowling said uh for someone to go
out of their way to make a website about
these urban legends there must be some
small grain of Truth to them I don't
know like I kind of feel like I'm really
into
I don't remember if we've ever done a
show about this but I'm a big fan of um
the folklorist John Harold brunvand if
that's how you pronounce his last name
and he's written several books about
different urban legends like his whole
thing like he used to have like for a
long time he had like a newspaper column
and then like he compiled them into a
bunch of books and so he's like
fascinated in tracing where these
stories come from
some of them are sort of kind of based
on real things that happened not usually
though
but it's really interesting because a
lot of he's interested in them because
of what they say about
um what's going on in the culture at the
time like this is what
you know this is what the overriding
fears of the culture were at the time
and it came out in this particular urban
legend which was really popular you know
during this time period so to me that's
like why it's interesting like folklore
is interesting because you can really
tell a lot about a culture like what
like what they fear what they value
stuff like that like from what they what
they come up with in their stories and
particularly their horror stories yeah
you know check out Christian mythicism
mythicism is a great [ __ ] study
there's a lot of channels on it on
YouTube now it's [ __ ] blossomed out
I'm now a Christian mythicist cultural
Christian none of that actually happened
none of it
just like it's just like Greek mythology
and Greco-Roman mythology and then it's
the same authors more or less
but it's all valuable doesn't mean hey
it's not important it's no it's
important it's just it's as important
it's just as important as the MCU or DC
or Star Wars is it's just called These
are cultural
this is It's a cultural artifact stories
of what's valuable like I said that's
why I find it interesting that's why
folklorists find it interesting yeah
they don't really I don't think they
really particularly care whether it's
true or not no they just care of like
why do certain things like take hold in
the culture like why is everybody
telling this particular story during
this particular time like what what is
that speaking to like and in in the
culture at large like what is everybody
like you know anxious about it's a
method of teaching truth
and if it's not true then the Legends
die out or expressing like I said some
particular anxiety that's going on at
that you know a fear or a value or
something like that that's going on okay
so let me go ahead and pass the
collection played around people were
probably uh what is it halfway or
two-thirds the way through the show wait
are we this is a this is a Monday show I
can't see we've been on for almost two
hours God damn you know that right oh so
we're towards the end okay we're towards
you okay so I'm gonna go ahead and uh
Pass the Plate around and
um did you think it was Wednesday or
Friday I don't know what time it is
I'm just thinking about what I have to
create for us to eat after the show is
over I don't know something yeah all
right I wouldn't mind a couple of
Roll-Ups with that crab salad yeah
that's what I was thinking I could do it
with something like that that'd be good
so uh now so is this is is it done yeah
okay it's done okay so now tomorrow yeah
which is Tuesday I know it's not a
haunting Tuesdays but maybe
since it's already almost eight o'clock
yeah we should probably do another
haunting episode I think we should so
because it's only an hour to watch those
things or 45 minutes to watch those
things and we've seen them several times
and we'll come up with a good show for
them for tomorrow and like y'all like
the hauntings and it seems there's a lot
of response for this so we should
probably do another one I kind of feel
like yeah and like I said we've I have a
couple more of that people have
requested like over the weeks
so uh one particular I remember
everybody requesting was the presents
okay so we'll find out and we'll do that
one tomorrow instead of doing a movie
because yeah like I said thank you very
much I'm really sleepy and it's like I
only got like four or five years and
it's like so I don't know if I can sleep
to like sit through a whole movie thank
you Jeffy Art thank you yeah thank you
very much uh yeah so if if there's any
super chaps or tips would be appreciated
at this point we're gonna stay on and if
you guys want to ask any questions we'll
stay on for a little while and then uh
okay you gotta talk though because I
gotta go to the bathroom all right
you've already I'm gonna go through I'm
gonna go through like two or three times
yeah yeah I yeah I can't I can't drink
all this and then just like sit here the
way you are yeah I'm a man I'm a man men
don't have the damn bladders that women
have women have bladders the size of a
dab basketball evidently they're they're
trained to hold it I don't hold it you
know because I'll [ __ ] unzip and let
that [ __ ] fly okay let's see what
everybody's talking about
so yeah black frogs asking yes so we're
gonna have another haunting tomorrow yes
we're gonna have another haunting
tomorrow because they're popular and
they're uh they don't take long to watch
and we've seen we've seen the episodes
so many times I can just remember them
they're enjoyable man those those early
classic hauntings uh episodes you know
we have them all on DVD they're [ __ ]
fun to watch
I got a real
kind of soothing [ __ ] soundtrack to
him in a familiar cast that they're
constantly showing you kind of the same
people over and over again
and uh the the cases were interesting
in like the first five six seven seasons
you know season eight so far we're
watching and it's uh kind of uh you know
but I'm gonna [ __ ] do 9 10 11 12.
we're gonna get them all we're gonna see
if they get better
they might get better
the only thing that's kind of pissing me
off is that season eight is available
digital only no physical medium and I'd
like to have a physical medium for this
um if I pay money man I want a physical
item you know
but uh
it's a short season anyway so let's see
what people are saying
all right Tom what do you think of the
Star Wars sequels okay so you must be
talking about
Force awakens and all that
Force awakens I thought it was going to
be pretty good I thought they were kind
of laying out a new Trilogy and I I was
like yeah this is going to be good
they're they're working with something
here
and then Ryan Johnson's ones came out
and just like no no he [ __ ] that all
up and then the third one uh what was
the name of that [ __ ] I don't even
remember the name of the third the third
one right Skywalker rise of Skywalkers
that was called
the third one would have been a lot
better if the second one didn't exist
it's almost kind of like they tried to
reverse a lot of that
and then they tried to overcompensate by
doing [ __ ] over the top [ __ ] like
[ __ ] riding damn space horses across
the tops of [ __ ] Star Destroyers and
all this crazy [ __ ]
I like some of the stuff with the
emperor and the dark side stuff later
although I would have never brought that
dude back uh it's just
man that third one was really [ __ ]
messy and it was messy because of the
second one
um
if I was if I owned Disney I'd have all
that [ __ ] Struck from Canon I'd [ __ ]
I'd I'd Disappear all three of those
movies I'd start over and do them again
that's what I would do
and I'd have I'd have the guy that did
the [ __ ] Mandalorian do him
because he kind of understands Star Wars
whoever wrote this [ __ ] does not know
anything about Star Wars
they don't know what made the old Star
Wars great
the sequels made the prequels look
really good
I can go back and watch the prequels now
and go yeah well this is Star Wars It's
Star Wars I mean there's a lot of [ __ ]
in there I would have done I would never
had a Jar Jar Binks and I would have had
a lot more Darth Maul I would have
[ __ ] changed some [ __ ] around the way
they handled Anakin and has turned to
the dark side I I did a show on it me
and Jenny did a show and I just I said
how that [ __ ] really should have gone it
should have been in a damn Civil War
where the [ __ ] morals were so gray he
thought he was on the right side hunting
down that would have been a lot I kind
of feel like the way they did it in the
prequels it was just kind of like oh by
the way I'm evil now I'm just like no
yeah I didn't buy that no it's not I
didn't buy it should have been that
Anakin really thought he was on the
[ __ ] on the right side of the force
because villains that's what makes
villains interesting is they actually
kind of a lot of them think they're the
good guys he should have been down there
killing who what he who he thought were
Sith
Sith infiltrators and then later on it's
revealed that no the whole time he was
killing Jedi and that he's working for
the Sith and then that and then that
could have been twisted around on him to
where he's like [ __ ] I got fooled and
then the emperor could have said see
that's the weakness with with the Jedi
and the force is that y'all are too
gullible and you know this and then blah
blah if you had been on the dark side
you would have seen these lies to begin
with yeah I would have never been able
to fool you and you know there's a bunch
of different ways where that could have
gone and then he then you you you then
Anakin would have been like yeah I so I
guess the force is really the truth of
the force is really the dark side that
that's where it's really true yeah there
were more believable ways right I could
have yeah so there's because there's I
mean there's analogs in real life that
you could like look to for that right
right but like look to like the way
somebody gets sucked into a cult right
exactly like you know you know there's a
lot of studies on that like you could
use that as a jumping off point right
and then you know the emperor would have
been like those Jedi that you killed
they died because they were too weak to
defend themselves from you which right
there proves that we're on the right
track because things that are true are
always true and have the ability to
defend themselves and they they can't
defend themselves against this they
gotta go
were the force this is what the force is
about
but here's the problem here's the
problem with with Lucas what made a lot
of the Great
movies from the original
trilogy so good is that Lucas didn't
have that much to do with them you had a
lot of British [ __ ] guys directed
stuff and [ __ ] good writers and Lucas
is more of an idea man well in good
editors good editors yeah so editors are
like the unsung heroes yeah
and the worst of the original series was
Return of the Jedi and Lucas had the
most to do with that one and it had it
had problems
um it wasn't a bad movie it just had
some problems
so you can't let Lucas just do what he
wants he's not he's not that kind of
dude
you have to have somebody to be able to
say no to him
there never should have been a Jar Jar
Binks that was stupid you know but
nobody had the balls to say no to him in
his own company
yeah I mean that was that was lucasfilm
that was his company the thing about it
maybe that somebody did was like me man
that's a dumb idea and then maybe that
dude got fired that's what I'm telling
you
and you got fired or they didn't listen
to him right you know what I mean so so
you know I don't know if somebody's out
there like some guy or gal that worked
there and we're like hey I tried to tell
him it was a stupid idea but he didn't
listen to me so no and Lucas always
wanted these to be kids stories but the
kids that grew up watching those grew up
into adults and you should he should
have [ __ ] changed that material to a
more adult
audience because kids didn't give a [ __ ]
about that
when those [ __ ] new Trilogy came out
kids didn't give a [ __ ] about Star Wars
didn't know what that was and they're
trying to still sell toys to them and
they didn't even know that's what worked
like back in the 80s and like I said
yeah but kids don't care if we give a
[ __ ] about toys today well and the thing
about it too is that everybody that like
saw Star Wars as kids in the 80s are
grown-ups now yeah and they're the ones
that are excited about the new ones so
Market towards them they get like a more
adult you could have sold those toys but
you'd have been selling those toys to
adult collectors
which they do do now but that should
have been the main [ __ ] thing kids
don't give a [ __ ] about those toys and
another thing is is that when I was a
kid the reason why I liked [ __ ] the
original Star Wars series is because as
a kid I I did not have the feeling that
that's that that series was talking down
to me I thought I was watching a really
adult movie
you know wow this is some badass [ __ ]
first time I'm seeing robots oh man out
of space look at all this [ __ ] and it
was I could understand everything that
was going on but it was not talking down
to me like I was a little kid adults
were along with it along with a ride and
everything that's what made Star Wars
great it was not a kid's movie it was
General audience real exciting General
and honestly I will say that that's kind
of like a really hard thing to pull off
I kind of feel like a lot of people
think it's maybe easy to write for kids
or write for like a y a audience or
write for a general audience it's really
not it's very difficult to strike a
balance between something that will
appeal to adults and also be
comprehensible to kids but without being
like condescending it's like really
really hard to strike a balance between
that so when they do that and like a lot
of filmmakers did that really well in
the 80s
um but a lot of them [ __ ] it up too
I'm not gonna say like you can very
easily go on one side or the other like
it's too adult like kids are just like
we don't give a [ __ ] about that or you
make it to too kiddish and like adults
don't want to watch it now I saw a fan
at it of the first three movies the
print the prequels
those three prequels edited down into
two movies and it was great
so the prequels actually could have been
really improved by a much better edit
but it would have only been two movies
block frog said or it gets too creepy
like The Dark Crystal although I loved
the Dark Crystal I couldn't rewatch it
though honestly yeah it's not as good as
I remember like now I'm not gonna say
that about like Labyrinth because that
is absolutely as good as I remember
that's still awesome Dark Crystal is
still awesome but I don't like it as
much as I did back in the day
Labyrinth is the ultimate young woman
movie but anybody can watch it but I
watch it now from the point of view of
like what would a what would a 12 year
old girl 13 year old girl well it's a
it's a girls coming of age story but
it's there's no warning about men it
well and it's universalized too it's
like it's in a fantasy guy so it's like
even dudes can watch it and like think
it's cool because there's monsters and
[ __ ] in it yeah
um but girls can watch it like teenage
girls can watch it and they get like
something extra out of it you know what
I mean which that's cool I think that's
good and like I said that's hard to do
and honestly the Labyrinth
um
I think
I was that came out in 86 yeah
so I think I was almost exactly the same
exact age General as Jennifer Connelly
was and Jennifer Connelly she was cute
as [ __ ] I was in high school maybe she
was a year or two older than me but
still but similar I was in high school
when that movie came out we watched it
we [ __ ] liked it in high school and I
didn't really catch all the messages I
couldn't I wasn't really mature enough
to know that to see what this was that
this was basically instructing women to
be careful of guys who are too old or
Too Young or too big or too strong or
too strange well dudes that it's
basically saying yeah they're basically
like yes these older dudes and they'll
seem very like cool and mysterious yeah
[ __ ] like that but they're just like
trying to get in your pants yeah so like
watch but that's what they call that
[ __ ] they're predatory and then the fact
that [ __ ] up can be down and that the
rules are not what you think they are an
African the rules don't matter there's a
lot of [ __ ] great messages in in that
well there's also a message too where it
it's kind of teaching her to be less
selfish and to take responsibility for
people other than herself yeah and in
the end though it's very traditional in
the end it's about saving the baby
well like I said um well there's a
reproductive message in there yeah but
that's in a way that's a little bit
reductive because I mean the story is
like yeah she saves the baby but I think
like generally it's more saying
um don't be selfish
um you know you have to like look out
for other people too right because she's
very very selfish at the beginning she's
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] it's like I hate
myself no responsibility I don't really
want to take care of my stupid brother I
want to do my own [ __ ] I want to live in
my own fantasy world but then she
realizes that she has to like live in
the real world and take responsibility
for people other than herself so it's
not just about the baby it's just about
you know finding a world like Beyond
yourself and like taking responsibility
you know I looking at it now as an adult
I think it's a [ __ ] excellent writing
it is yeah I still love that man yeah
excellent writing and it's um
it's it's mythology that is actually
what mythology is
and uh no I think it's [ __ ] great if
I had a daughter that's what I'd be
showing her I'd razor razor on that kind
of [ __ ]
oh I would yeah that's absolutely a
movie though and then because I loved it
she's like well and as they get older
you're like what does that mean and then
you [ __ ] explain to him what that
little Fable meant
yeah
and uh yeah some like sexy ass David
Bowie [ __ ] with his pants and
he's like your dad's age that's right
and he's in them damn you watch it
[ __ ] you think he's the [ __ ] okay you
gotta and like I guess we all love the
pants yeah we did that [ __ ] bouncing
side to side and then the little the
ball yeah the little flat and the little
fire demons trying to give each other
heads like pulling their heads off and
you give me some head and this and that
you gotta watch out watch out on all
that [ __ ] that's what that's exactly
what they're talking about yeah
smoking things and giving head
yeah yeah
you can't control it and the funny thing
is I I imagine
sometimes sometimes like because I'm a
writer too so I get it like sometimes
they're absolutely aware of the messages
that they're sending sometimes not
though like sometimes I think some
things come out that they didn't
necessarily intend but then like
everybody reads into it is that I don't
know I think that one they were pretty
aware of what it goes into the Labyrinth
and the first thing she meets is a
middle-aged little worm man come in Meet
the missus
where should I go that way oh I don't
know I don't give a [ __ ] about you
you're a teenager girl I got things to
do with the missus I'm still working I
loved aloe you know that's the middle
they should make a whole movie that
little worm the message the mess with
his little blue hair the message to the
young girls is that middle-aged men who
are married can't help you they're good
in their own thing you're gonna have to
figure this [ __ ] out on your own yeah
yeah you're coming to me
but you know can't help you can't help
y'all girls I love that little worm yeah
like I said they should make a whole
movie yeah so everything in that movie
had a meaning but it was very good
writing very good writing well and
Hoggle was kind of like that too because
he's the old dude he was he was kind of
like loved her yeah he loved her but he
was too old he couldn't believe it was
too old too too old couldn't deliver and
there's you know and [ __ ] he's the
end of his life and the thing exactly
young fox who [ __ ] claims to be able
to do all this [ __ ] but he can't deliver
he's riding around on a dog but he's too
vitamins yeah yeah but he can't really
do anything okay he doesn't have the
power to do anything he's guarding the
bird then you got a big dude who's
powerful but he's so [ __ ] dumb he
can't do anything either that's Ludo
yeah yeah so they're all talking about
all these extreme kind of men you know
and that's all these messages that a
young girl should know yeah it's like
these are some of the losers yeah that's
right as you go through your team
foxy little [ __ ] got nothing to
offer just talking
and then runs from the fight
than him
it is but like I said you don't have to
read stuff into it but it absolutely
isn't that's what they're talking about
and like I said um you know me being a
teenage girl and me being pretty much
the same age I think I was just a year
or two younger than Jennifer Connelly
yeah when I saw that movie so because
like I said that came out at 86 so I was
what yeah I was 14. laughing over
Bowie's bulge yeah yeah exactly I mean
it's famous and oracle's talking about
you remind me of the babe yeah the babe
with the power
yeah yeah they know they know they all
know that's a great movie made me want
to watch I got that [ __ ] on steelbook
I'm the only heterosexual man that has
that movie on steelbook well if anybody
calls you out on it you can just say
it's mine
it's hers I didn't buy that it's a good
example of [ __ ] really good writing
good Mythic writing
yeah well the reason I like that movie
is because for that reason because I do
kind of feel like I don't know maybe
less so nowadays but I do kind of feel
like
things that are targeted toward girls
like particularly teenage girls I kind
of feel like people kind of [ __ ] on it a
little bit Yeah so well mostly it's
poorly written
well mostly everything is important like
no matter who it's targeted at yeah so
the thing about it is that I do kind of
feel like people tend to [ __ ] on stuff
that is geared toward teenage girls
maybe not so much nowadays but they used
to so I kind of feel like to have
something like that that is generally
targeted toward teenage girls but like
you wouldn't get on a dude's case for
watching it because it's a cool ass
movie it's just like a fantasy and like
I said there's monsters and there's
crazy [ __ ] and stuff like that in it but
I don't know I just kind of like that it
appealed to everybody even though it was
mostly geared toward teenage girls yeah
you know I just I and I thought that was
like a really good
um
it's just hard to do like I said because
[ __ ] man when I was a teenage girl a lot
of stuff that was geared toward teenage
girls I don't like that [ __ ] yeah I like
the whole meaning of the story with
jareth and everything is that these
dudes only have the amount of power that
you give them
they have no power over you yeah
but that's that's that's you know that's
a good message
yeah it's a
story she's learning to take
responsibility for her own self she's
learning to be not selfish like to
realize there's a world outside of her
that the world doesn't revolve around
her which is something that a lot of
teenagers need to learn they're saying
stuff like that in there actually uh
they're talking about night of the Comet
which we should probably do a review on
that one of these days because that is
actually like a really good uh a really
good movie
uh let's see same with the Buffy the
Vampire Slayer film yeah that too it's
just kind of like
that's another one that actually yeah
was was kind of geared toward teenage
girls but like everybody can like watch
it you know what I mean that was a good
movie yeah
Jeffy art said I think I'm on a delay my
message from Labyrinth you can still
take responsibility and still be a kid
at heart yeah
exactly because at the end
you know yes she saves the baby and she
tells Bowie hey [ __ ] off or whatever
um you know you don't really have any
problems you don't have her overpower
over me or anything like that but then
at the end like she goes back to her
room with all her little like toys and
stuff in it and all of the you know uh
her little friends that she met along
where in her room and she's like I still
need you guys yeah so yeah another one
that was good in there was a little
character of the old lady with
everything everything on her back yeah
the message there was don't be a hoarder
little baby oh you need this oh you need
that and it's just no I don't need all
this [ __ ]
because that's what happens to some
women some of them
become old ladies that just hoard [ __ ]
that's a good story
but see that's the thing that we've got
to go to this before because we've
talked about hoarders yeah I think it's
a little bit disingenuous for the
hoarders show to almost like and I know
it's probably not their fault but I feel
like 85 90 of the hoarders episodes are
women even though in reality
there are more mail hoarders yeah
um but but in that particular movie they
wanted to show it right right right they
said that this could happen to you if
you don't know how to let things go yeah
because yeah that's exactly right yeah
but I'm just saying Hoarding in general
that's actually like it's it's not it's
a little bit more like common in men
than women but they show it more on the
hoarder show because I'm assuming
because men are too embarrassed to like
go on TV no the women want to go on the
show so the women want to be on the show
or at least their families are like
let's put this [ __ ] on the show we need
to clean this crap yeah you know what I
mean
yeah Danny Rowling said night of the
Comet inspired Buffy the Vampire Slayer
yeah that's right I don't I can't
imagine like why we haven't done night
of the Comet yet because I feel like I
just watched it not too long ago yeah
and I don't know why we didn't review it
but we probably should at some point
block frog says chili down was a good
song and it was yeah all the songs all
of them were good I had I had that on
tape back in the day when I was a kid
I'd play it in the damn school bus going
back home
I mean that's all the songs in there all
the songs on it we're good I was big
into Bowie when I was in high school in
Brazil and I liked that soundtrack that
was one of my lady in there I'd layer in
some Labyrinth
yeah which is hard to believe that that
is that old but yeah 86 yeah I was 14
when that came out yeah so when I was uh
87 as a senior I was still listening to
that
it was it was good it was a good uh it
was a good album it wasn't it was like
an EP though I don't think it was a full
album
yeah so you want to go ahead and shut it
down Jim yeah Oracle said do night of
the Comet okay okay we may maybe we'll
do it um Sunday because I think we're
gonna do another haunting tomorrow
outside of the comments when everybody
died and the girls running around in the
damage in the mall okay I've never seen
it wouldn't mind oh it's good okay it's
good all right they might still have it
on shutter I kind of feel like I watched
it on shutter now it's supposed to be
the ultimate dead Mall video that's the
ultimate dead balls it's one of the most
80s 80s movies the 80s of all 80s movies
uh yeah Oracle said half the girls I
knew wanted the ball gown from the dream
sequence in Labyrinth oh I did too
absolutely that was fantastic oh what a
great cosplay that would be oh holy [ __ ]
I just remember I should be back in high
school look at Jennifer Connelly and she
was just cute as [ __ ] man so I was like
she's still cute she looks bad and then
a few few days a few years later I was
in the Army and The Rocketeer came out
and she was [ __ ] swinging man she
looked great in The Rocketeer you have
never seen everything Dario argento's
phenomena have you no she's she's in
that as well she's in that okay she
controls uh bugs with her psychics she
went from being like a kid to just a
full-blown [ __ ] woman and it feels it
seemed like it was only like in a couple
years couldn't believe it was the same
woman same girl probably you should see
Darren aronofsky's uh what's that movie
why do I always forget the name of it
Requiem for a Dream yeah because
Jennifer Connelly gets uh railed in the
butt with a dildo oh [ __ ] so yeah okay
okay
I don't know you might be into it it's
actually
yeah they do it's actually a
double-sided dildo it's her and another
well she's a drug addict and like
they're showing like how like the point
that she's got down to it's her and this
other woman and there's like a
double-sided dildo like yeah okay like
at a party and everyone's looking at him
yeah it has to ask that's kind of all
right I can't believe you haven't seen
them yeah Jennifer Connelly's out okay
you probably just when did that come out
2001 early 2000s I want to say it's a
great movie I mean it's depressing as
[ __ ] she was really good in the elite a
battle angel
she still looks almost exactly the same
you know what else she was in that you
might like is um Dark Water which was a
remake of a Japanese horror movie by uh
I told hideo Nakata I think his name is
and uh yeah it's like a horror movie
like her and her daughter like live in
this apartment it's like all kind of
creepy like ghost shits going on yeah
it's good I like it well I mean the
original is good too but us the Remake
is actually really good let me make it
something to eat all right so we're
gonna eat so tomorrow you guys we're
gonna do another haunting episode uh if
I can stay awake during one because it's
already quarter past eight and I'm like
super super sleepy but we'll probably do
you want to do the presents okay yeah
we'll do the presents I don't even know
like when that would so I'm sure we have
it but I don't know like what season or
episode it is so if you want to watch it
like ahead of time uh that's what we're
gonna do tomorrow so it'll be like
another haunting special haunting
Tuesdays we'll be back tomorrow it's a
holiday week whatever we'll do it all
right so thanks everybody for dropping
by this afternoon evening and we will
see you guys again tomorrow thanks for
super chats and bye